when Tim Burton's The Nightmare Before
Christmas premiered in October 1993 it
did so with surprisingly little Fanfare
for a film developed by Disney it was
only after the film left theaters that
it began a transition from beloved cult
movie to cultural phenomenon the story
of how this creepy classic came about is
just as interesting as the film itself
here's the Untold Truth of The Nightmare
Before Christmas it comes from a poem
Burton originally pinned the movie story
as a poem when he was working as an
animator for Disney which he likened to
being stuck in a prison Burton could
never adapt to the style preferred by
Disney which became clear to him while
working on the 1981 feature The Fox and
the Hound saying I couldn't draw those
four-legged Disney foxes mine look like
roadkills Burton left Disney but kept in
touch with another struggling animator
Henry celik Burton shared his haunting
poem about a skeletal figure named Jack
Skellington with celic who showed
immediate interest in directing a
feature version production started in
1991 but not without some trouble salic
didn't even have a full script in the
beginning all he had was Burton's best
wishes and a few of Danny Elfman songs
to go on Disney got scared Disney
initially considered turning Burton's
holiday theme poem into a TV special or
a short film similar to Vincent a 1982
short film also based on a burton poem
but it backed out the success of 1988's
Beetlejuice and 1990s Edward Scissor
Hands gave Burton enough negotiating
power to arrange deal with Disney and
the project was finally green lit with
Burton acting as the goet for the studio
and his director but after seeing the
first trailer then chairman CEO Michael
Eisner decided that The Nightmare Before
Christmas was just too dark for Disney
the film was sent away from the Kids
Table to touch tone pictures where
Disney kept content they didn't want
associated with her child-friendly brand
what's wrong with disembodied legs and
children with sewn shut eyes anyhow
isn't that basically their slogan
filming took over 3 years hailing from
before the days of slick CGI the effort
that went into making The Nightmare
Before Christmas was intense the film
was shot at 24 frames per second which
meant that the characters had to be
repositioned 24 times for every second
of film it took a whole week to create
just a single minute of footage and
eight camera Crews worked at once it
wasn't just a case of nudging a figurine
slightly either the characters had to be
careful y disassembled and reassembled
for every frame so their facial
expressions matched what was happening
on screen the Pumpkin King had more than
400 interchangeable heads
alone Oogie Boogie was trouble despite
being a burlap saag filled with creepy
crawlies nightmare's antagonist Oogie
Boogie was actually the hardest
character to create his complex demise
in the film was particularly tricky to
navigate consisting of four shots that
each took a full month to make not only
not only that but the metal Armature
inside the huge figure was so strong
that animators had to get behind it and
push it into place for each shot so
there's no wonder he's barely in the
film well well well what have we here
Santa Claus
huh I'm really scared some viewers also
felt that Kim Page's portrayal of the
villain verged on racist celic defended
the character insisting that Paige
modeled his voice performance on cab
callow way this argument is supported by
the fact that some lines of dialogue are
lifted directly from the 1933 Betty Boop
cartoon The Old Man of the Mountain
starring Callaway what you going to do
now going to do the best I can what are
you going to do I'm going to do the best
I can composer Danny Elfman has a long
history of channeling Callaway as well
as he did in the 1980 film forbidden
zone well son let me tell you I'm so
pleased to meet you the boys and I've
been expecting to you best friends for
never all of Jack Skellington's songs
were composed and sung by Oingo Boingo
frontman Danny Elfman himself that's
nightmare trivia 101 but Elfman also
recorded all the Pumpkin King speaking
Parts too while he nailed the singing
elman's voice acting just wasn't up to
celic standards and in the end Burton
and celic decided they would have Chris
Sarandon re-record the scenes Elfman
took it badly refusing to score Burton's
next film Ed Wood Elfman still got his
speaking voice in the film kind of the
world-renowned composer also voiced the
clown with a tear away face and Barrel
the smallest of Oogie Boogie's miniature
henchmen whatever you say Jack Creator
cameos in the end elfman's voice being
in the movie just wasn't enough and he
had the animators create a shrunken
version of his head and hide it inside a
cello Tim Burton severed head was also
supposed to appear in the film's finale
as a hockey puck but the projectile was
changed to a Jackal Lantern at the last
moment rumor has it that Disney deemed
the inclusion of their former employes
head a step too far and leaned on celic
to change
it doctor in Disguise the biggest reveal
from the unearth storyboards was a twist
ending when Oogie Boogie sack starts to
unravel it isn't just worms and spiders
that come spilling out Dr finl Stein is
in there too yes Jack Skellington it's
me me the man who created Sally from
bits of Flesh and WPS of cloth but she
loves you jack you oblivious twit a
defiant finlin explains he wanted to
teach Sally a lesson before declaring
his intentions to make a new creation
and disappearing through a trap door the
doctor's gross New Creation can be seen
in the film's finale why anyone would
choose a wife that looked exactly like
themselves is anyone's guess but those
reasons are probably pretty weird lost
voices like Chris sandon many of the
films voices weren't the Creator's
original choices Burton had worked with
Vincent Price on two Productions prior
to nightmare but their collaboration on
nightmare had to be called off
unexpectedly price came into the studio
to record the voice of Santa but when
the veteran actor was too depressed
after losing his wife they were forced
to consider alternatives James Earl
Jones had discussions with Elfman that
ended in an angry shouting match in the
end Ed Ivory a relative unknown was
entrusted with the part Patrick Stewart
was also brought on the nightmare early
on in his development recording a film
length adaptation of the poem I'm sick
of the scaring the terror the Fright I'm
tired of being something that goes bump
in the night in the end it was decided
that the opening verses would be better
recited by the film Santa and the steart
version ended up on The Cutting Room
floor DVD extras and the film's official
soundtrack horror veteran Christopher
Lee also read the full length poem for
the film but was also ultimately cut to
his disappointment I'm sick sick of the
scaring the terror the Fright I'm tired
of being something that goes bump in the
night but as we all know Lee is no
stranger to being stabbed in the back
skeleton babies the last that Jack and
old Sandy Claws see of each other is
when Santa flies out of sight leaving
Halloween Town under a blanket of snow
in an unused epilog scene however Santa
reveals that he actually visited his old
friend Jack years after their holidays
disastrously crossed paths and found him
with a handful full of musically
inclined children by his side so many
years later I thought I'd drop in and
there was old Jack still looking quite
thin with four or five skeleton children
at hand playing strange Little Tunes in
their xylophone band those kids actually
sound a lot like Oingo Boingo now that
we think about it there's kind of a
sequel and a prequel in the mid 2000s
Capcom released a video game called
ooi's Revenge which takes place after
the events of the film Jack gets bored
with his life again UGI is sewn Back
Together by his Trio of henchmen and the
burlap sack decides he wants to be the
king of all holidays not just Halloween
the game ends pretty much identically to
the film with Oogie once again defeated
and Jack once again rededicated to his
true calling of Halloween no one said it
was a great story but there's a video
game prequel also the Pumpkin King
released at the same time as a sequel
actually explains the huge gaps in the
film's continuity the conflict and
jealousy between Jack and ooie is
explored as well as exactly why ooie has
to live underground in his lair spoiler
alert it's because once again he lost a
fight with Jack Jack's cameos Burton is
declared he'll never create a real The
Nightmare Before Christmas sequel
especially not one where Jack goes to
Arbor Day town or something excuse me is
this Hanukkah town no it's the Vatican
and I'm P but that didn't stop celic
from returning to the character twice in
his 1996 adaptation of r dolls James and
the Giant Peach the Brigade of mutant
insects face off against Jack as a
pirate with one even declaring well a
skeleton the skeletal master of horror
does his job pretty well but that's not
even his only Cameo celex 2009
stopmotion film Coraline evokes
nightmare in a number of ways though
those with a Keen Eye were able to spot
a direct reference as Coraline's mother
cracks eggs over a bowl Jack's grinning
skull can be seen inside one of the
dripping yolks it's almost a literal
Easter egg but it's so quick it's easy
to miss others not so
[Music]
much
bunny there's kit there's camp and then
there's whatever is happening here even
if you're someone who thinks the 1978
Star Wars holiday special is
delightfully Bonkers you got to admit
that there are a few aspects that are
rather nightmarish
agreed before the opening credits fans
are treated to a brief scene in which
Han Solo promises to get Chewbacca back
home in time for Life
day I know your family's
waiting I know it's an important day
after we're dazzled by the star studded
main title sequence we get to meet
Chewy's whole family and that's when The
Dread sets in sure Wookies are
theoretically lovable but they're just
really grading
here
[Music]
suddenly there's a huge room full of
roaring Wookies each with a different
vocal pitch and continually moaning for
several minutes straight is this not
super annoying to
[Music]
you the craziest part their
conversations aren't translated for the
audience there are no subtitles
whatsoever it's a welcome relief when
chewy rambunctious Sun lumpy such
settles down to watch some hologram
acrobats do their thing but even after
this bizarre spectacle you find yourself
wondering what on Earth am I watching
what are they going on about why are the
dancers wearing Sparkle bikinis it's
very unsettling stuff on the best of
days it's also really
aggravating throughout the special it's
insanely obvious that the young Star
Wars Stars aren't too thrilled to be
appearing in the special har and Ford
sounds particularly bored that's it I'm
turning back meanwhile Mark Hamill caked
in what appears to be several pounds of
TV makeup evidently has no idea where he
is or what he's supposed to be doing at
least he looks like he might actually be
receiving Transmissions from space
what's up it's chewbaca and Carrie fiser
an actress who never shied away from
discussing her prolific drug use during
this phase of her career is clearly well
let's just says she's coping with the
production as best she can Mala it's so
good to see you happy life day Harvey
Corman was a comedy treasure he was a
staple of the 60s and 70s pop culture
landscape thanks in no small part to His
Brilliant work on the Carol Bernette
show and in classic Mel Brooks films
like Blazing Saddles his personnic
screen Persona and impeccable comedic
timing made for so many Unforgettable
moments unfortunately none of these
moments can be found anywhere in the
star holiday special in fact Corman pops
up not once not twice but on three
different occasions and playing three
different characters all of which we'll
get to in a hot minute let's start with
the first one gormand is a television
chef and Chewy's wife Mala clearly loves
her cooking show she watches gormand
intently as she prepares the family's
life Day dinner of course if your family
has a hearty appetite I would suggest
them that old popular holiday favorite
the banther rump gormand is evidently
the science fiction equivalent of Julia
Child it's a premise that's not without
comedic potential but there's just
something about the frenzied manic
energy that we find deeply unnerving
stir whip stir whip whip whip stir stir
whip stir whip whip whip sorry gormand
you and your four spider-like arms seem
to mean well but you're just a bit much
for our delicate
sensibilities no disrespect to the late
Diane Carroll but exactly how did this
cameo come about perhaps she thought a
Star Wars special sounded like a plum
gig and she certainly did the best she
could with what she was given it's just
that what she was given well there's
really no way to put it delicately as
you can see and you can never unsee she
depicts the holographic object of
unbridled wook lust is it getting hot in
here Chewy's father nickname of itchy is
enjoying what's called a mind evaporator
this handy Gadget is perhaps responsible
for the Star Wars holiday special's most
UNC comfortable moment the wookies
family friend Shawn played by
honeymooner star Art Carney of all
people gives itchy a very special life
Day gift kind of hard to explain it's
a wow you know what I mean it takes a
while for her to come into Focus but
suddenly there she is the legendary
Diane Carroll playing some sort of
Intergalactic disco nymph much to the
Delight of the dirty old W oh
yes I can feel my creation
I'm getting your message yeah we're
getting all the messages after her coily
seductive introduction she launches into
a performance of the song this minute
it's a perfectly lovely tune if perhaps
very very very very long and itchy makes
the whole thing feel well itchy the way
he Grunts and the way those rancid gums
flap excitedly it's all a bit much we
can have a good
time can't we
and in case you think any of this is
accidental we should mention that the
shooting script specifically indicates
that Shawn presents his gift as if he is
giving itchy the most x-rated piece of
literature in the
Galaxy much like gormand the second
character played by Harvey Corman is
also part of an instructional video
drone Boyd is a not so Plucky robot who
appears on screen to teach a certain
lumpy hi lumpy how to assemble a mini
transmitter so is drone scen better or
worse than Gourmand does well it's
different very very different the joke
in this sequence if you want to be
generous and call it a joke is that
drone boy has a tendency to break down
slurring his speech and occasionally
unable to
move sometimes he talks very slowly or
stops to adjust various robot parts
that's it that's the whole thing and it
goes on for several minutes the worst
part drone boy's appearance occurs about
2/3 of the way through the special and
by that point you're already starting to
get concerned that this thing is never
going to end and then suddenly you're
asked to deal with this kind of material
let us work slowly or methodically
because this is a
job in one of the special's many awkward
scenes we find ourselves at the Moss
eely Cantina the place where Luke
Skywalker and Obi-Wan Kenobi met Han
Solo and Chewbacca for the first time
and this is where we eventually meet
crownman the third and final Harvey
Corman character before you can say
mclunky he's already making your skin
crawl crowman is chatting up the
unflappable bartender ammina played by
the inimitable B Arthur in what is
clearly an ongoing one-sided flirtation
it's played like an old-fashioned comedy
routine with two Charming performers and
the special sharpest writing akina's
prickly dialogue is genuinely funny
especially with the laser blast
Precision of B Arthur's delivery
unfortunately none of that can SA save
the scene from the icky feeling of
watching a nice guy refuse to take a
hint uh excuse me I have a customer
waiting I'll be right back come back
soon I'll be
waiting look at poor ammina Bound by
professional courtesy to put up with him
if perhaps none too politely it's all
just way too real I just came in here
for a drink and I found a lot
more
kman there's also a bit of a physic ick
factor in the way crowman pours a drink
into a hole in the top of his head is
that a second mouth up there that's just
always open weird dude the good times at
The Cantina come to an abrupt end
following a major buzz kill of an
announcement oh no not on life day due
to increased activity among subversive
forces we are placing a curfew on the
entire Tatooine system effective
immediately that means ammina has to
Usher all her loyal patrons out possibly
forever getting the alien revelers to
leave proves to be a challenge fellas
the party is
over and so she burst into a rousing
number called good night but not goodbye
it's a song that would get just about
anyone out the door in a jiffy the whole
thing is of course deeply silly but it
also turns out to be surprisingly
heartfelt bar Arthur as always gives it
her all strident pleading to a room full
of rubberhead monster masks is it just
us or does the whole scene end up rather
affecting in the end really it all feels
a bit like Casablanca but with a
hammerhead and what exactly is the
relationship between akina and this
humanoid rat they're awfully tender with
one another anyone thoughts hello Star
Wars has always seemed to rip off some
real world conflicts fortunately the
films are so fast-paced Fantastical and
full of space Wizards with laser swords
you never get a chance to start dwelling
on our real issues here on Earth but the
stakes get a little too real in the Star
Wars holiday special especially since
it's presumably geared towards
undiscerning children there's the
aforementioned scene in which
authorities clamp down on so-called
subversive activity and then there's
this scene in which a stormtrooper tears
apart a young wook's bedroom in search
of hidden Rebels happy
holidays in fact the Empire has never
felt more like a Nazi regime than they
do here the special pays a lot of
attention to the domestic lives of
civilians you see them preparing for a
joyous holiday celebration but the
festivities occur beneath the looming
shadow of encroaching fascism it's
bizarrely heavy-handed stuff for a
holiday special no as the Star Wars
holiday special approaches its climax
chewy arrives home with an intensely
bored looking Han Solo who basically
manages to trip a stormtrooper to that
storm trooper's death like what just
happened here at last reunited with his
desperately annoying family chupaca
begins preparations for Life day
apparently this highly anticipated event
involves everyone grabbing whatever orbs
happen to be lying around and then
marching slowly and determinedly in
their red cloaks towards a large open
space then they just sort of stand there
finally Princess Leia bur send a song a
life day Carol titled a day to celebrate
and it just so happens to be set to the
tune of the main Star Wars theme oh the
pageantry this all begs the question
what on Earth is life day in the intro
to her song leam mentions this is the
promise of the Tree of Life hm first we
ever heard anything about this tree of
life presumably this is a huge trunk in
the background right is this tree trunk
part of the tree of life we may never
know then there's a druggy Montage of
random Star Wars scenes as everyone
stands around presumably meditating on
just how rad Star Wars is maybe that's
the true meaning of life Day Star Wars
is red the winter of 1978 was only a few
months removed from the record blasting
box office run of Star Wars many
theaters kept the movie playing for well
over a year past its May 1977 debut with
The Empire Strikes Back still a year and
a half away the prospect of a Star Wars
holiday special was obviously a big deal
just imagine the thrill of hearing an
announcer finally rattle off the names
of all your favorite Star Wars
characters and then this happened R2D2
as
R2D2 that one's a bit of a heads
scratcher isn't it as true adherence of
the force know R2-D2 was originally
performed by the late Kenny Baker who
controlled the Droid in both the
original and prequel trilogies and
usually from inside the costume there
are conflicting reports as to whether
Baker was actually involved in the
holiday special sometimes he's credited
with working on the 1978 spectacle but
it's worth noting that filmmaker Mick
Garis lists remote controlling R2-D2 for
the holiday special as one of his
earliest gigs regardless claiming R2
simply played himself as a bit insulting
to the performers involved and it
suggests the Droid somehow went sentient
for this cheesy variety show of course
there's also the distinct possibility
that no one wanted to take credit for
r2's performance here the Star Wars
franchise is of course a monster success
which makes the Star Wars holiday
special very special indeed and though
the films all have a Timeless quality
about them the holiday special is very
much a product of the' 70s in fact it
looks like your screen has been lightly
smeared in Vaseline but where else can
you find R2-D2 existing alongside
Jefferson Starship playing them elves
and also playing one certifiable clunker
of a song The Star Wars holiday special
is unique surprising woefully misguided
and an absolute joy to watch and yes
it's disturbing unless snuggling up to
drunken space rats is your idea of a
good time then again who are we to judge
Love Is Love I find you
adorable I'll tell you a
secret I find you
adorable the Santa Claus is one of the
most frequently discussed movies in the
whole Christmas Cannon that's partly
because when you look at it closely some
of its details actually seem kind of
bizarre nonsensical or even downright
disturbing here are some things kids
might not notice about this modern
holiday classic the central conceit of
The Santa Clause is that if something
bad happens to Santa the next person who
puts on his suit will inherit his title
of course the movie works well as a
comedy because the person who happens to
do that Scott Calvin doesn't want to be
Sant at all but is guilted into putting
on the suit by his young son Charlie and
inevitably the magic and spirit of
Christmas eventually win Scott over but
not until after a considerable struggle
that struggle is the heart of the film
but this all raises one unsettling
question what if someone terrible had
put on that suit Scott can be kind of a
jerk but he's still a pretty decent
person what if a hardened criminal had
gotten their hands on the suit and put
it on say as a disguise what if they'd
ignored or never even seen the reindeer
what if someone who killed Santa
intentionally rather than accidentally
fell subject to the claws honestly it's
a very poorly thought out system
troubling contractual issues shoes aside
Scott does put on the suit and manages
to Bumble his way through delivering a
few gifts with Charlie before the
reindeer take them back to the North
Pole once there he's greeted by well by
absolutely nothing the reindeers simply
run away to their stables for the night
before an elf shows up and without
saying a word puts in a code to make the
sleigh descend into Santa's headquarters
the rest of the elves and basically
ignore their new boss as he hops out of
the sleigh and starts asking questions
when head elf Bernard finally does talk
to Scott He seems annoyed that he even
has to fill the new guy in and the rest
of the elves appear neither pleased nor
concerned to see the new Santa walking
around like a deer in headlights what's
even more concerning is that none of the
eles seem to care at all that the old
Santa just died and vanished into
nothingness did they really hate their
old boss that much does this happen all
the time so they just don't get attached
everyone knows North Pole is supposed to
be cold but jeez speaking of the old
Santa the film never once stops to
address his past life or Legacy at the
North Pole we don't know if he was a
particularly good or bad santa we don't
know how long he was on the job we don't
even know how well he got along with the
elves this stuff is obviously brushed
over so the film can get on with Scott's
story but the Santa Claus 2 suggests
that it's hugely important for Santa to
get married and even eventually begin a
family did the last Santa do those
things if so what happened to his Mrs
Claus is she long dead did she retire
from the North Pole upon his death or
was he too new on the job to even
contemplate that these are all things
the story ignores in favor of a plot
contrivance that allows an ordinary guy
to become Santa after the old one is
defeated by a slippery rooftop but
something still doesn't add up here the
Santa Claus is a relatively short movie
and it's not until the sequels that
you're given a better look at the whole
mythology of the North Pole and the
people who populate it what the movies
never explain however is just where the
actual Santa Claus comes from when Scott
returns in the sleigh Bernard and the
other elves don't seem all that
surprised that they have to train a new
Santa which suggests this isn't the
first time a father Christmas has died
on the job nobody explains how long the
contract has been around but it's fair
to say that it's probably very very old
meaning the mantle of Santa Claus has
been changing hands for some time so who
actually wrote this contract how did it
become hidden in the fine print of that
little card who nailed down the
technicalities does the North Pole have
a legal department clearly this thing
exists because Santa needed to be
replaced one time and the elves realized
that they had to create a legal
precedent for getting a new one but the
exact details as to how this came about
are sadly never revealed once Scott
arrives at the North Pole and finally
gets a little explanation from Bernard
the head elf seems to decide to calm him
down rather than bombard him with too
many details which is fair enough of
course so Bernard sends Scott to his
room to get some rest Judy will take to
your room get out of the suit it needs
to be cleaned and taken in then get some
sleep we've got a lot of work to do and
only a year in which to do it sleep on
it and you'll learn more later seems
like a fair attitude to take with a
panic new employee but Scott actually
wakes up in his own bed at home with no
memory of how he got there and more
importantly no further instructions from
the North Pole so like anyone would he
writes it off as a weird dream but then
his body starts to change proving that
his trip to the North Pole really
happened even then however there's still
no word from the elves the first real
contact he receives from Bernard is the
list in the form of thousands of
packages stacked throughout his house
after that things only get more manic so
much for easing the poor guy in Scott
Calvin initially dismisses his role as
the new Santa as nothing more than a
weird dream but he soon finds that
ignoring his new role has some physical
consequences he starts to gain weight
literally overnight his facial hair
begins to grow at a supernatural rate
and he develops an insatiable appetite
for dessert foods when it all gets bad
enough Scott does what most people would
probably do in the same situation he
goes to his doctor after a thorough
checkup Scott's doctor delivers his
patient a healthy dose of um optimism
okay look so what you put on a little
weight a little weight does this look
like a little weight to you weight can
fluctuate from year to year the doctor
confirms that he can't find anything
medically wrong with Scott so he
basically just tells him to go home eat
less and dye his hair now this is
clearly a busy general practitioner who
just wants to calm his patient but you
can't help but wonder why he isn't
digging deeper and why Scott isn't
asking him to if Scot had just offered
to shave right there in the office and
the doctor watched the hair literally
grow back he'd be sure to take notice at
the very least he'd get a good research
paper out of it the Santa Claus is a
film that hinges on belief and the
central conflict involves Charlie's
steadfast belief that not only is Santa
Claus real but that his father has now
become St Nick himself this creates
tragic issues within Charlie's family as
his mother Laura and stepfather Neil
become convinced that Scott is making
himself appear to be Santa in order to
take Charlie away from them it also
plays the classic Christmas Story Trope
of adults not believing in Santa Claus
like children do Laura and Neil even
discuss this while they recall the exact
moments they stopped believing in Santa
because they didn't get the gifts they
asked for I was
three and it was an Oscar Meer weenie
whistle here's the problem though the
audience knows that Santa is real and
that means these families all wake up on
Christmas morning to presents that
weren't there when everyone went to bed
but how do the parents feel about this
is there some strange magic spell that
convinces them they put them there do
they simply forget which presents they
bought and which ones they didn't are
they just confused doesn't matter that
much to the plot but it would have been
nice to get even a throwaway explanation
for this since the film spends so much
time dealing with the parents
beliefs okay so in case you've never
seen this movie it's probably worth
knowing that some of the elves have
jetpacks these elves are known as the
effective liberating flight squad or
elves and they're first called into
service when Santa is arrested at Lauren
Neil's house now setting aside the idea
that a man who can fit down any chimney
somehow can't do anything about prison
bars the movie's elves with Attitude
stick raises a whole new problem for
Santa and his North Pole crew this is
because the elves stage a very flashy
and not at all covert extraction of
their boss from jail they tell the cop
on duty that they're his worst nightmare
wrap him up in ribbon And Shove a donut
in his mouth then they cut the door off
Santa cell with some kind of high tensil
tinsel and simply steal him away now
you've got to hand it to the elves for
having the forethought to launch their
raid on the one night where the station
is manned by Just One Cop but that
doesn't clear up the other problems
namely that there's now going to be a
police report and even probably some
surveillance footage depicting a group
of apparent children and magically
ribboning up a cop and abducting a guy
dressed like Santa that's going to make
for some very weird team meetings once
Christmas is over obviously despite all
the weirdness the Santa Claus has a
happy ending Scott finally accepts his
job as the Avatar of Christmas joy and
flies off to the North Pole having
converted Neil and Laura to his cause
and forged a loving lasting relationship
with his son what the ending doesn't
address however is what happens to Scott
Calvin the human you know the guy with a
house and a job and presumably a series
of public records that include paying
taxes having a driver license and owning
property later films in the franchise
confirm that Scott still maintains his
civilian identity in some form as he
occasionally arrives in the human world
to visit Charlie but it's never
explained how far this goes he could
simply be showing up introducing himself
as Charlie's dad and then going back
home weirder still when Scott first
meets Bernard the head elf tells him he
has 11 months to get his Affairs in
order does that mean vanish his former
self fake his death or does Scott Calvin
now exist in this weird in between World
in which his identity is maintained only
by diligent paperwork managing elves
these are Big questions people at the
very end of the film Neil tells Charlie
he would make a great psychiatrist one
day Charlie however decides he's going
to walk a different path no I think I'm
going to go into the family business
it's a sweet moment if you disregard the
fact that Neil is also his family and
Charlie just burned the Poor Man's whole
life's work with that comment but it's
also kind of a weird remark to make in
the context of the film story Scott
became Santa because the last Santa died
and there are no other humans present at
the North Pole does Charlie mean he's
going to move up there and just live
among the elves or does he mean that
he's going to wait for his dad to die
and then take over his Santa suit he's
just a kid so he's probably not really
thinking this through but if it's the
former how would his adult life proceed
for him if it's the latter does he not
realize that his dad is going to have to
die for him to fulfill his Newfound
dream talk about disturbing
implications Christmas is a time of
comfort joy and Coco by the tree but if
you're in the right kind of mood it's
also a time for killer Santa demon IC
elves and other seasonal frights if you
want to curl up by the fire for a
monstrous movie marathon here are the
best and worst films out there for your
Yol tide sleigh black Christmas is the
Twisted godmother of holiday horror
films the plot is a familiar one with a
mysterious killer picking of victims in
a sorority house around Christmas but
more than four decades after its release
this winry slasher still wins over
viewers with its haunting holiday tone
the film features terrifying murder
sequences compelling performances and
one of the most unsettling phone calls
in horror movie history all set against
a cozy Christmas backdrop just like
having a
w oh my God nearly a decade later
director Bob Clark did a complete
turnaround with a very different holiday
classic the slightly less violent A
Christmas Story now that's a double
feature y'll sh your ey y'll sh your ey
up
[Applause]
it's no surprise that black Christmas
got the extreme remake treatment but
louder gorier and darker doesn't
necessarily equal better released in
2006 this second Incarnation attempted
to flesh out exactly what was behind the
brutal murders at the sorority house and
while the answer to that mystery is
satisfyingly bizarre it does pull time
away from the victims and their stories
aside from spelling out the Killer's
Origins the Remake attempts to
distinguish itself through increasingly
disgusting murder sequences but it's all
just soulless violence with little charm
or fun to be found for all its effort to
grow its mythology and serve up Twisted
kill scenes the end result is both too
much and not enough there are plenty of
Christmas movies that explore the
mythology of Santa Claus each one hoping
to add something to the legend few films
really succeed at this one exception is
rare exports a finnished film that
offers a fascinating creepy new take on
Father Christmas perhaps the best thing
about the film is the way it plays with
the tropes of Christmas movies there's a
struggling family a boy searching for a
reason to believe in magic and some
wonderful Supernatural happenings all
twisted into a frightening fantasy tale
it's a film that both celebrates and
subverts Christmas shattering the
Illusions its characters have about the
holiday as the dark truth about Santa
Claus is Unearthed for at least one
Christmas Eve you'll be thinking about
St Nick very differently you probably
don't want to let that guy in your house
Silent Night deadly night is a campy
slasher classic with one of the best
posters in Horror history but its sequel
is mostly a dull retread of the first
film and is about as much fun as a lump
of coal thanks to a flimsy framing
device the movie spends a huge chunk of
its runtime on flashbacks as a result a
whole lot of footage from the first
movie is reused by the time the film
gets around to new material you're bored
enough to turn it off you may as well
stick with the original or press pause
on the horror movies and go spend time
with your
family why would I want to do that if
you're looking for the creepiest film
about Aila Santa then see out Christmas
evil it's the story of a man whose
perception of St Nick was forever warped
by a childhood incident leaving him
feeling responsible for keeping the
spirit of Christmas alive himself that
warped Vision ultimately makes him want
to be Santa keeping tabs on local
children which despite Santa's example
is an insanely scary thing to Do It All
Leads up to a murder spree that plays
out in a way that's much less campy than
you might expect forget the reason for
the season this is just a Bonafide
horror film with a desire to truly scare
that makes it an underseen
gem your name goes in the bad boys and
girls
book and I'll bring you
something horrible Jack Frost has not by
traditional standards a good movie it's
the story of a serial killer whose DNA
merges with snow after the truck taking
him to be executed crashes into some
toxic goo he then takes a form of a
sentient shape-shifting snowman who
terrorizes a small town with his crappy
visual effects despite failing with both
critics and audiences Jack Frost has
stuck around since its 1997 release
seemingly blissfully unaware of just how
bad it is do you want a holiday movie
with a bit of spooky flare that won't
Scar the kids for life then watch
Gremlins Joe Dante's classic About a Boy
at his strange pet Christmas present has
been a source of imaginative fun for 30
years every 80s kid knows you can't feed
a marai after midnight even if Gremlins
2 admits that role doesn't really make
sense oh wait a minute what about this
what if they're in an airplane and they
cross a time zone I mean it's always
midnight
somewhere Santa slay might be a bad
movie but it's hard to watch without
having a good time famously starring
professional wrestler Bill Goldberg the
film goes all in on its premise of a
murderous Santa and this is no mere
imitator this is a real deal Chris
Kringle coming straight out of the
depths of Hell Santa slay is pulled by
demonic reindeer and he keeps things
brutally unbrand taking out all of his
victims and seasonally appropriate way
this villainous St Nicholas isn't just a
Santa gone mad he's a Santa born bad
it's so stupid that it's awesome but
it's still really really stupid the
internet's favorite Christmas monster
has a movie well worth watching kumus
starts as a story of a dysfunctional
family coming together for a tense
holiday reunion with one side being
uptight and the other being a little gun
crazy when one of the kids loses the
Christmas spirit and shreds his letter
to Santa things quickly take a chilling
turn a blizzard sets in and the power
goes out leaving the family waiting for
a visit not from Santa but rather his
Dark Shadow well made and delightfully
feisty Krampus is a Creature Feature For
All Seasons a work of horror comedy that
just works on every level enough
murderous Santas how about a killer elf
most of this horror unfolds at the
department store where a group of
teenagers and an ex cop Santa
impersonator are spending the night it
turns out they aren't alone because a
strange elf creature is also roaming
around raising hell they have magical
powers they can't be hurt or killed they
eat anything they're a perfect soldier
that sounds like an okay premise but
elves get so much stranger the Dan
Hagerty starring movie is so bad with a
story so bunkers that it's actually kind
of good what do Santa's Little Helpers
have in common with a secret Nazi plot
it's way more than you'd expect you'll
have to see it to believe it but you
just might wish you
hadn't ranging from funny to festive
these holiday favorites are just waiting
for you to binge at your Leisure and
whenever you get started it will be the
most wonderful time of the year here's a
look at the best Christmas movies on
Netflix if you're a bit of a Christmas
cynic you could always spike your eggnog
and sit down with bad santa a comedy
about a man who uses one of The Season's
most enduring symbols to gain the trust
of everyone around him and then Rob them
blind while also getting blackout drunk
sure it might seem a little
mean-spirited but Bad Santa is actually
part of a grand tradition of Christmas
films including the Beloved classic It's
a Wonderful Life that use misfortune and
misery as entry points into discovering
the true meaning of the season in this
case the person who needs to discover it
is Willie soak played by Billy Bob
Thorton a safe cracker who's sick of his
life masquerading as a m Santa when he
meets a naive but good-natured boy named
Thurman Willie finds his life slowly
beginning to take on meaning again
whether he really wants it to or not
it's unapologetically foulmouthed and
surprisingly joyous by the end and
features a terrific Supporting Cast that
includes the late John Ritter and Bernie
Mack plus if you're having fun with Bad
Santa Netflix can always carry you right
over to the sequel Bad Santa 2 in the
years since Love Actually was released
it has divided viewers with the hottest
Christmas media debate since Baby It's
Cold Outside set in the month leading up
to Christmas it has a cast of well
basically every British actor you've
ever heard of including Alan Rickman D
Grant Kira nightly Liam niss Mr Bean
Bilbo Baggins and Rick from The Walking
Dead thanks to its interweaving stories
of love it's been called the ultimate
romantic comedy and embraced as a
holiday Essential by many while
dismissed as an overwrought Mess by
others who think it has some pretty
dubious ideas about romance it's a
debate we still have every Christmas but
after all that dust settles we still
want to watch it every single year some
viewers May dismiss a Christmas Prince
as another generic Royal romantic comedy
that the filmmakers just slap some
Christmas decorations on if you actually
sit down and watch it though you'll find
charm hearts and a story that rings
every little bit of joy out of what it's
given to work with rose mcgyver stars as
a young reporter eager to catch the eye
of her boss by infiltrating the Adian
monarchy and learning what's keeping the
mysterious Prince Richard from claiming
his rightful place on the throne after
going undercover as a tutor to the
prince's young sister surpris she
quickly falls in love with Richard only
to find that there are enemies out to
stop his coronation on Christmas Eve
it's not the most lavish production
you'll ever see but there's a reason
Netflix dropped a sequel this year
here's hoping it becomes an annual
tradition with increasingly ridiculous
plots Santa Buddies is a warm little
movie perfect for kids who love cute
dogs and holiday cheer the story
revolves around Puppy Paws the son of
Santa's dog Santa Paw because of course
that's his name who's a bit worn out by
Christmas and just wants to be a normal
puppy maybe you should be thinking about
how important Christmas is to children
and puppies all around the world Puppy
Paws leaves the North Pole and tries to
learn how to be a regular puppy from a
few who happen to be on Santa's naughty
list what Puppy Paws doesn't know though
is that the very fate of Christmas
hinges on him learning a lesson about
the true Spirit of the holiday and he'd
better learn it fast before the
cold-hearted dog catcher played by
Christopher Lloyd can ruin everything in
other words it's the exact plot of Elf
but with an adorable puppy instead of
will frell believe it or not though it's
both adorable and weird enough to be
watchable the only real problem with
showing it to your kids is that they
might decide a puppy is the one thing
they want for Christmas get Santa is yet
another film that follows a recognizable
holiday formula this time it's the tale
of the young child trying to convince a
cynical adult that Santa Claus is real
The Twist is that get Santa takes that
premise and mixes it up with a Kinder
gentler version of a guy Richie crime
comedy and the results are as strange as
they are delightful ra spall stars as
Steve a former getaway driver fresh out
of prison and eager to reconnect with
his son Tom Tom is a bit disinterested
but calls his father for help when he
believes he's found Santa inside a shed
hello mate how are you how how you doing
Santa's in the
garage what this Santa claims that his
sleigh cracked and his reindeer have
been scattered and asks for help only to
end up locked in prison instead with
Christmas on the line it's up to Steve
and Tom to find the reindeer enlist the
help of some Elves and get Santa that is
if Steve can ever find his way to
believing in Father Christmas again it's
a wonderfully weird little movie with a
new Twist on a classic taale plus a
version of The Journey to the North Pole
or elf city as it's called in the film
you've likely never seen before if
you're after an enduring holiday classic
full of musical numbers gorgeous
Technicolor imagery and the Exquisite
comic timing of Danny Kay then white
Christmas is for you I want you to have
nine children and if you only spend 5
minutes a day with each kid that's 45
minutes and I'd at least have time to go
out and get a massage or something like
many holiday films of its time it
doesn't entirely revolve around
Christmas but rather builds to it by
telling the story of four entertainers
who find themselves at an inn in Vermont
only to find that December hasn't
brought any snow with it yet like the
characters the audience Waits virtually
the entire film for anything wintry or
Christmas y to show up but when it
finally does it proves to be absolutely
worth it in addition to Kay's comedic
Mastery the film also features Bing
Crosby in one of his most famous roles
Rosemary Clooney showing both her acting
and singing chops ver Ellen's incredible
dancing and some of the most memorable
musical numbers you'll ever see oh and
there's also a pretty good song in there
you might have heard of this film has
lived on in the hearts of Christmas
movie fans for more than 60 years and a
single viewing is all it takes to
understand why Netflix isn't just
excelling in the fair fairy tale
princess Christmas romcom Department
they've also branched out into more
humble even somewhat quirky offerings
aimed at everyone who enjoys cozy low
stakes Christmas Fair enter the holiday
calendar the story of a small town
photographer stuck in a rut both
personally and professionally her life
seems to be going nowhere until her
grandfather gives her an antique Advent
calendar that once belonged to her late
grandmother those are predicting
[Music]
future how much why have you had tonight
the calendar will only open its doors on
its own magically at midnight each night
in December revealing a unique charm
that will prove to have some meaning in
her life the following day through the
Calendar's magic Abby thinks she finds
love then realizes there are bigger
lessons to be learned from this strange
little family artifact the Christmas
calendar like so many Christmas romantic
comedies is ultimately predictable but
its charm is such that you won't really
care if you see the ending coming
sometimes the most casually enjoyable
Christmas movies are arve when you take
a tried and true romantic comedy formula
and just sprinkle a little Holly and
mistletoe through it all that's the case
with Christmas wedding planner the film
follows wedding planner Kelsey as she
attempts to plan and execute the perfect
holiday wedding her biggest problem
isn't the venue or the bride but a
private investigator who's threatening
to expose the truth about the couple at
the heart of the ceremony and wreck the
whole wedding you expect me to believe
that some mysterious person hired you to
ruin this wedding well technically
looking at thought but um ruin the
weddings a potential outcome in an
effort to keep the pi happy while still
delivering the dream wedding she was
hired for Kelsey agrees to join his case
and help him get to the bottom of it of
course if you know romantic comedies at
all you can probably guess what happens
next after a long day of shopping this
is exactly the kind of light crowd
fasing holiday fair to throw on while
you're wrapping presents Dear Santa is
one of the best known and most beloved
of the 21st Century's large crop of made
for TV Christmas romances that
frequently circulate on Lifetime
Hallmark and now Netflix it's a growing
subg genre and a steady rotation for
many fans and Dear Santa is a big reason
why Amy AER plays Crystal a rich girl
who's facing the threat of being cut off
by her parents if she doesn't find some
sense of direction when she stumbles
upon a letter a little girl wrote to
Santa asking for a new wife for her
widowed soup kitchen running father
Crystal takes it as a sign that she's
meant to be a part of their family of
course not all goes according to plan I
didn't do anything I just happened to be
here Netflix Devotion to original
programming led to an even bigger
holiday movie boom in 2018 than we've
seen in previous years and that may have
reached its peak with the Christmas
Chronicles a film that blends a little
bit of the Santa Claus a little bit of
found footage and a whole lot of Kurt
Russell into a very enjoyable package
the film follows a pair of children
whose family has been devastated by loss
as they try to get along together on
Christmas Eve when young Kate believes
she spotted Santa in an old family home
movie she persuades her brother Teddy to
stay up with her for a Stak out one
thing leads to another and the siblings
find themselves face to face with the
real Santa Claus who's very different
than Decades of marketing have made him
out to be no need to wake up early there
won't be any
presentence you two are on the naughty
list for life with little time and a lot
of frustration the trio has no choice
but to team up find Santa's lost
belongings and save Christmas it's
exactly the kind of charming romp you'd
expect from the producer of the Harry
Potter movies and a director who worked
on Frozen and Wreck-It Ralph only
weirder A Charlie Brown Christmas has
become a Bonafide holiday staple if
you're an adult who's watched the show
multiple times there are several details
you may have noticed about this seasonal
classic that younger viewers likely miss
let's
investigate just as pigpen is
perpetually surrounded by dust clouds
and Schroeder is almost always next to
his piano lius is hardly ever seen
without his trusty blue blanket he's got
it with him outside in the snow and
inside during rehearsals for the
Christmas play lonus you've got to get
rid of that stupid blanket he's quite
clearly attached to the thing perhaps a
little too
attached you think you're so smart with
that blanket what are you going to do
with it when you grow up maybe I'll make
it into a sport coat you can't blame
lonus for not wanting to let the blanket
go it appears to be made of 100% pure
magic it gets dragged through the snow
all day without getting dogy and even
serves as a remarkably accurate
slingshot wait did he just ice skate
with his security blanket in his hand
and now this is happening later on Lucy
tries to get him to put down the blanket
so that he can dress up like a Shepherd
for the Christmas play That's when lonus
reveals that the blanket can shape shift
forming a perfect headdress complete
with a band in the middle who
manufactures this Swiss Army security
blanket we simply must have one a good
chunk of A Charlie Brown Christmas takes
place at the the local Auditorium where
the Peanuts Gang is getting ready to put
on a Christmas play Charlie Brown is
roped into the production after he tells
Lucy about his holiday depression and
she feels the play will help him get
into the holiday spirit you want me to
be the director of the Christmas
play sure Charlie Brown we need a
director you need involvement Charlie
Brown eagerly leaps into his role as
director but he can't seem to get anyone
to listen to him perhaps more
importantly no one seems in entirely
clear on what play they're even putting
on at one point Lucy hands out scripts
to various kids for roles like inkeeper
and Shepherd obviously this suggests
stivity play but then she also asks
Snoopy can you be a
sheep how about a
cow how about a
penguin quite the managerie all told to
complicate matters further Schroeder
keeps trying to score the play with
upbeat Jazz and at one point Lucy
suggests herself for a plum sounding
role what about the Christmas Queen H so
is this some sort of Highly conceptual
staunchly Avant guard Nativity Play is
it a variety show does anyone really
know to our ears it all sounds a tad bit
unfocused A Charlie Brown Christmas
begins by focusing on the titular
character's own lack of satisfaction
with the holiday he tells lonus in no
uncertain terms Christmas is coming but
I'm not happy I don't feel the I'm
supposed to feel he also repeatedly
complains that the holiday has grown too
commercial his scrooges reaches dizzying
New Heights when he sees Snoopy putting
up a bunch of decorations on his
dogghouse that's when he realizes the
Beagle is decking the halls for a
Christmas light contest that's promising
at cash prize oh
no my own dog gone commercial I can't
stand it oh by the end of the special we
learned that Snoopy not only entered the
contest but managed to win first place
we admit that Snoopy's decorated
dogghouse looks very Charming but we
have a few concerns he puts lights up
all around the roof hangs a
theoretically festive chain or two and
even tops it all off with a star there's
nothing wrong with his decorations per
se but It ultimately amounts to little
more than a strand of lights and a
couple of bobles hanging around a
dogghouse how did this dogghouse win out
over all those Suburban properties come
to think of it Charlie Brown's name
neighb don't appear to have put in much
of an effort where's everyone's
Christmas lights apart from the ultra
commercial Christmas tree lot it looks
like people just weren't feeling it that
year maybe Charlie Brown had every
reason to be
depressed when the Christmas play
rehearsals don't seem to be working
Charlie Brown makes a passionate plea
look Charlie Brown what do you want the
proper mood we need a Christmas tree
Lucy agrees and advises Charlie Brown to
get a great big aluminum Christmas tree
Charlie Brown and lus subsequently head
to the tree lot where they ultimately
decide to take the scrawny real tree
that remains one of the most famous
parts of the show the whole point of the
scene is that Charlie Brown picks this
little twig of a tree which mirrors his
own feelings about the season but when
you look around at the rest of the lot
you may have some questions it's
arranged like a traditional Christmas
tree lot but it soon becomes clear that
the tiny tree is the only real tree
there the rest are made of
aluminum this really brings Christmas
clothes to a person
fantastic setting aside the lack of real
trees for a moment let's ask the obvious
question who's selling aluminum
Christmas trees outside where it's
clearly been snowing snow is wet and the
trees are made of a delicate metal
surely that would have messed up the
merchandise no when Charlie Brown brings
the tiny tree back from the lot and
presents it to his friends they call him
names and fullon laugh at him then lonus
makes a stirring speech passionately
quoting scripture in the hopes of
emphasizing the true meaning of
Christmas that's when Charlie Brown
decides to take the tree home he thinks
he can convince everyone that they were
wrong to make fun of the tree so long as
he can get the decorations right Charlie
Brown gives up after the tree nearly
breaks in half from the weight of just
one ornament but then the other kids
come along to help lonus wraps his
blanket around the base and the kids use
all the decorations from Snoopy's
dogghouse to fill out the rest of the
tree by the time the kids are done
decorating with all the lights and
bubles the tree looks like it's grown
about a dozen extra branches and a whole
bunch of extra needles in fact it looks
like a completely different tree is it a
Christmas time
Miracle what's going on
here in the many years since home
alone's release in 1990 it's become
evident that while Kevin McAllister's
solo U tide Adventures are still
tremendously fun to watch there are a
lot of things about this film that are a
little too bizarre illogical or even
downright disturbing if if you're a kid
watching Home Alone Kevin's dialogue
feels almost aspirational the things he
says to his parents and other family
members are the kinds of things we all
wished we could say when we were young
but probably never have the nerve to do
so when his mom tells him to leave her
room for example he responds H up the
phone and make me why don't you and then
when she tells him to go upstairs after
he shoves his brother buzz in the
kitchen he shouts back upstairs I am
upstairs dummy granted Kevin is in the
midst of being punished when he says
this but still calling your mom a dummy
and suffering zero consequences would
have felt like a dream for young movie
goers however as an adult it's a little
hard to overlook just how rude Kevin is
and how his parents either ignore it or
laugh it off to be fair most of the
other mallister kids are just as bad if
not worse so Kevin really doesn't stand
out that much in comparison making the
idea of traveling to Paris with so many
disrespectful kids sound more like a
nightmare than a vacation still
considering that Kevin is the
protagonist it's a little weird that
he's characterized as being just as
unpleasant to be around as the rest of
the kids in his family even even if you
put aside the fact that the mcallisters
have clearly spent a small fortune
decorating every inch of their expensive
home for a holiday they're not even
going to be home for have you ever taken
a close look at the rest of that house
it's not just the seasonal decorations
that make it feel festive the entire
interior design scheme seems to have
been planned around the holiday just
consider the green kitchen counters and
red pots and pans or the red green and
white patterned wallpaper covering the
walls of nearly every room in hallway
and there's also the parents red bed
spread the framed red flowers on their
walls and the red and green Furniture in
the living room the kitchen floor is red
the dining room walls are red the
upstairs walls are green the living room
has a red and white rug on the floor and
green curtains framing the windows even
the telephone is Green from lampshades
to Bath robes to prominently placed
teapots it's hard to find a single
surface or person in the mallister house
that isn't decked out for the holidays
all the time after living in such a
festive home year round it's no wonder
the mallister children seem to be fresh
at a Christmas cheer by the time
December arrives when Kevin shoves Buzz
for saying he ate Kevin's entire cheese
pizza Buzz falls into some cups of milk
which spill all over the passports and
airline tickets on the kitchen counter
the next morning during the hubub to get
everyone out of the house into the
airport on time Kevin's dad Peter
mentions that the passports are in the
microwave where he put them in order to
dry them off this microwave plan was
probably a bad idea for several reasons
although passports in 1990 wouldn't have
had the radio frequency identification
chips contained in modern passports
which would have caused them to burst
into flames in the microwave they still
would have had plastic covers which
would have melted the passports also
would have contain small amounts of
metal and the foil stamping on their
covers in the inner security features
which would have caused them to catch
fire Peter's lucky he didn't cause the
whole trip to go up in Flames although
at least in that case Kevin wouldn't
have accidentally been left at home by
himself Kevin's mom Kate realizes on the
plane that she left Kevin behind and the
first thing she does after landing is
wrestle a pay phone away from a French
woman so she can call the police what
follows is a frustrating series of
conversations as Kate gets transferred
from one Department to another and
conveys her story over and over to board
officers who seem more interested in
preparing for Christmas than in ensuring
a child's safety if you're a kid
watching the scene it's easy to get
annoyed at the police especially at the
officer who later goes to the mallister
house knocks once then gives up and
leaves when no one answers the door
surely this Police Department is the
height of professional incompetence
right as it turns out though maybe not
when Kate calls all she says each time
is yeah hi look I'm calling from Paris I
have a son who's home alone our phones
there are out of order so I'd like
somebody to go over to our house tell
them that coming home to get him she
never mentions Kevin's age or the fact
that he's not supposed to be alone
instead she comes across as an
overprotected parent who purposely left
her teenager at home and now wants the
police to make sure he isn't throwing a
rager while she's away no wonder the
police didn't bother investigating
further when Kevin didn't answer the
door it can seem illogical that Kevin
never calls the police until the end of
the movie choosing instead to construct
an elaborate series of booby traps to
protect himself but by Kevin's logic it
actually makes sense he thinks he made
his family Disappear by Magic and when
when he later encounters the wet Bandits
he recognizes Harry as the police
officer who visited his house earlier
police can't help with a magically
disappearing family and they may in fact
be the bad guys if Harry is one of them
but it's less clear why the pizza guy
doesn't call 911 after he delivers a pie
to the mallister home and Kevin uses the
angels with filthy souls video to trick
him into believing someone is trying to
kill him the ruse clearly works but then
nothing happens if he's under the
impression that one of his customers
just tried to kill him he' think he'd
call the police or at least report it to
his man manager who could pass the
incident along to the authorities but it
appears that instead he just keeps it to
himself and goes about the rest of his
day during the break in Extravaganza at
the end of the film Kevin knows to be
ready because the wet Bandits
inadvertently tell him to expect them at
9:00 but when he sets up his elaborate
fake party all he knows is that two
creepy guys in a van were hanging around
outside his house earlier in the day he
had no way of knowing what time they'd
be coming back or if they were even
planning on returning at all yet somehow
he managed to be enthusiastically
dancing at the precise moment when Harry
and Mar drove by that night either Kevin
was incredibly lucky with his timing or
he'd already been partying for hours
with his cardboard Friends by the time
the wet Bandits finally returned the
most plausible explanation is that he
had the whole party set up ready to go
as soon as their van turned onto a
street kept a close watch and it was a
lot less complicated than it appeared
for him to put all the cutouts in motion
but it's more fun to imagine that he was
just rocking out with his inanimate
guests all day although the church scene
between Kevin and old man Marley is
heartwarming it's hard not to notice
that it's also a little odd while
watching it as an adult even if you put
aside the fact that Kevin is in a church
an hour before the wet Bandits are due
to arrive and he has to run home in
order to make his battle plan work in
time there are still a few elements
about the scene that are kind of strange
when you examine them closely it makes
sense that old man Marley would come
over to introduce himself to Kevin and
tell him that he doesn't need to be
afraid of him after all it would have
been hard for him to miss his young
neighbor fleeing from him in Terror
earlier in the movie however it's a
little bizarre that Marley then proceeds
to unload all of his troubles with his
estranged son onto to a second grader
he's only just met and whose parents are
nowhere in sight of course we understand
that Marley means well especially when
it comes to Kevin's rescue with the end
of the film but typically adults don't
have impromptu heart-to- hearts with
unaccompanied miners they don't know of
the many traps Kevin sets for the wet
bandid one that could have proved
disastrous is the electric charcoal
starter that he hangs from the front
door knob the idea behind it is simple
even if the physics are a little advance
for a second grader Kevin plugs in the
starter inside the house hangs it on the
indoor metal knob which conducts the
Heat to the outdoor knob and ultimately
Sears an impression of itself onto an
unsuspecting Harry's hand after Harry
gives up on the front entrance Kevin
leaves the starter plugged in and
hanging on the door keeping in mind that
it had already been on the door for
about an hour before Harry showed up
that starter was probably left
unattended for at least a couple of
hours before Kevin turned it off in that
time there would have been a serious
risk of the door and subsequently the
entire house catching fire it's pretty
cool that you didn't burn the place down
the traps that Kevin sets for the wet
Bandits at the end of the movie all seem
like like delightfully funny pranks when
you're a kid but as an adult it's easy
to see the many ways it could have
resulted in death both criminals take
some serious blows to their heads and
the rest of their bodies during the home
invasion sequence any one of which could
have proved lethal first there's the
iron dropped on Mar's face via the
laundry shoot to which Falls three
stories to hit him squarely in the
forehead that's enough for severe facial
trauma and bone fractures then there are
the paint cans both Bandits take to the
face which could have taken their heads
right off and let's not forget the
Crowbar that Marv used to whack Harry in
the chest which could have broken his
ribs punctured his lungs or pierced his
heart and that's not even taking into
account all the other injuries boltman
likely suffered as a result of Kevin's
less lethal traps somehow we doubt that
the McAllister's VCRs and jewelry were
worth all of that you guys give up or
you thirsty for more while it's
understandable why the police don't seem
to take Kevin's plight too seriously
earlier in the movie it's a little less
easy to follow their process at the end
after receiving Kevin's call that the
Murphy's house is being robbed the
police arrived to discover Harry and
Marv significant worse for wear
presumably still being watched over by
old man Marley in his shovel Harry and
Marv are arrested and Kevin watches from
the window of his house where he then
goes to bed and peacefully awaits
Christmas morning why don't the police
ever question Kevin they must have
wondered why the wet Bandits were so
beaten up and in such a weird way what
with the feathers and burn wounds on
Harry and the iron shaped impression on
Marv's face even if Marley attempted to
take responsibility for it the bandits
were fully conscious when the police
showed up and they would likely have
been grumbling about the kid that did
this to them it's bizarre that no one
ever comes to get Kevin's side of the
story and in the process realize that
he's home by himself if the police were
better at their jobs Kevin's mom
probably would have arrived home to an
empty house and the message that her son
was at the police station sure it would
have taken away from the moving family
reunion at the end but it would have
helped with everyone's Peace of
[Music]
Mind A Christmas Carol adaptations range
from the delightful to the derivative
just how do the many iterations of
Dickens classic tale of redemption Stu
up from the total disaster ERS to the
heartfelt
Classics
hambur here are A Christmas Carol
adaptations ranked from worst to best
have you ever thought to yourself that A
Christmas Carol could use some slapstick
animal gags to under cutle the Victorian
Gloom how about a sleeker younger ebena
Scrooge who's given a second chance at
love perhaps a love song performed by
Kate winlet no well that's too bad
because 2001's Christmas Carol the movie
is stuffing all that and more into 81
minutes of tooth gritted cheer it's not
just that stuff that makes this take on
deckin so skippable despite the aless
talent Christmas Carol the movie It's
remarkably lifeless the facial animation
doesn't ever look quite right the acting
is at best stiff and the entire
operation feels dumbed down this
adaptation fatal flaw is that it doesn't
trust Dickens and it doesn't trust its
audience this 2003 TV movie attempts to
liveen up the classic tale by replacing
Scrooge with a selfish talk show host
and moving the story from Victorian
London to Modern day Hollywood it's an
intriguing idea on its own what setting
better represents a story of greed
empathy and false fronts on Hollywood
and hey isn't the idea of Scrooge as an
image obsessed celebrity pretty great in
concept it's all strong and Innovative
too bad the execution isn't a Carol
Christmas is little more than a Fresh
coat of paint that flakes away over the
course of the movie revealing that it
wasn't all that necessary to begin with
the modern setting makes dickin story
more cloying than anything else removed
from suti London the sickly children and
terrifying visions of the future feel
more like after school specials and
Grave warnings worst of all a Carol
Christmas is simply boring by the end
the audience isn't so much watching the
movie as it is waiting it out the cranky
celebrity might learn to be kinder by
the end but the viewer has only learned
to distrust new takes on Old favorites
there was a sliver of time in the 2000s
when movies fell in love with surreal
motion capture powered computer
animation Robert zamis fresh from using
this technique in the polaro express and
baywolf decided to apply to A Christmas
Carol led by performances from Jim
Carrey as Scrooge and Gary Oldman as Bob
cret the results were odd some like
Roger eer tailed it as an exhilarating
visual experience others like the
telegraph considered its looks
distracting creating distance between
the characters and the audience that
made it difficult to connect to the
story there's more of gravy than of
grave about you whatever you
are years later the movie's reputation
remains mixed and it's not hard to see
why there are certainly strengths to be
found Carri Scrooge is a bit goofier
than other Renditions but it fits the
ghoulishly funny tone of the movie and
oldman's cratchet is Pitch Perfect but
the visual so dazzling in 2009 looks
strange to Modern Eyes plus the tone of
the film sits uncomfortably between two
extremes it's a little too dark to be
heartwarming and a bit too silly to be
Bleak only one thing is truly clear it's
nobody's go-to version when the holiday
season rolls around you might not
recognize Alam Menin by name but there's
a good chance you know his work The
Little Mermaid Beauty and the Beast and
Tangled all feature his songs so when he
signed on to a brand new adaptation of A
Christmas Carol starring Kelsey Grammar
hopes were high The Man Behind A Whole
New World and Under the Sea tackling one
of the greatest holiday stories ever
told that's just not a good idea it's
about as safe a bet as anyone gets in
the entertainment industry and yet
somehow this version of Scrooge's
fateful transformation leaves something
to be desired the music is quite good
though it never hits the highs of man's
greatest work the story is solidly told
and the movie features a fine
performance from Jane Kowski as the
ghosts of Christmas Past grammar is as
grumpy as Scrooge should be without ever
crossing the line into total awfulness
and yet the entire Affair is somehow
inert it never stops feeling like
something adapted from the stage that
probably should have stayed there on
film it never offends but it doesn't
impress either it's trapped between
worlds unable to succeed in either one
Disney has been involved in multiple
Christmas Carol adaptations but this is
the one that features a characters most
Central to the brand Mickey Minnie and
of course Scrooge McDuck all starring
this particular take on the tale they
bring a certain lightness to even the
darkest parts of the iconic story no one
heads into A Christmas Carol thinking
Scrooge won't end up changing his ways
but there's still something soothing
about Mickey Mouse Leading The Bleak
first half of the story for the youngest
viewers this is an ideal Carol
indeed well
eaner unfortunately that's the only
group this version is meant for anyone
beyond the preschool years won't find
much to love about this take blunted as
it is by Disney's core characters this
isn't to say it isn't sweet to watch
beloved figures like Daisy Duck and
Goofy in London learning the ways of
Goodwill toward men the sheer number of
a Christmas car adaptations though means
that no viewer has to settle for mere
sweetness leave this version in the
nursery where it belongs and move on to
something better unique among Carol
adaptations Scrooge actually features an
in Universe staging of the classic tail
shrew TV executive Frank cross ordered
it and he doesn't care how much strain
it puts on his overworked employees he
is of course the scroge of this story oh
my gosh does that
suck he's even got an overworked
assistant a widow named Grace and an old
flame whose work with the homeless
contrast sharply with his greed three
ghosts visit him lessons are learned and
in the end Frank leads the Carol crew in
a rendition of the 1969 classic Put a
Little Love in Your Heart spins on Carol
can go quite well and this one does for
the most part modern mass media suits
the protagonist and it's different
enough from the original story to be
intriguing but similar enough to
translate smoothly Bill Murray in the
title role plays cross with Sharky
calculating Menace he's a Scrooge the
audience fears on a primal level as he's
so destructive in a familiar way but
there is a mean-spirited tone to the
film as though the movie is embarrassed
to seem too Earnest this pairs oddly
with the sentimental ending which
actually goes further down the road to a
happy ending than most carols all in all
it's fun but only just this isn't the
only animated rendition of A Christmas
Carol on our list but it might just be
the most visually striking so much so
that it w an Oscar for best animated
short film Richard Williams who
masterminded Who Framed Roger Rabbit
directed and produced this version and
the quality is clear in every frame this
version of A Christmas Carol is a steer
almost da thanks to the crew looking to
19th century in cravings for inspiration
as a result this version might not be
the one children respond to Plus this a
short piece only 25 minutes long you
can't help but wish the film had a
little more room to breathe if only to
explore the possibilities of its unique
animation more still the end result is a
gorgeous half hour of pure Dickens as
warm-hearted as it is deliberately Rough
Around the Edges you forget the happy
ending within the grimy first half of
the tail so it's all the more delightful
to ReDiscover that in the second Dickens
work isn't exactly what anyone would
describe as feel good sure A Christmas
Carol has a happy ending but the reader
needs to earn it D Kenan after all has
become a descriptor into itself and this
version of A Christmas Carol AKA Scrooge
is truly deenan British giant of the
stage and Screen alist Sim duns a stove
pipe hat in this adaptation and he
cranks up the grumpiness to memorable
levels it's a notably Grim take on an
already dark tail but it works for the
most part due to Sims unbeatable scream
presence you hate Scrooge but you never
give up on him that's staring Central
performance livens up the whole
production making the film actively
entertaining instead of Simply fa to
Dickens this is a deeply honest
Christmas Carol for better and worse but
it never loses its faith in Humanity's
ability to change a version of A
Christmas Carol starring Patrick Stewart
already has a leg up on the competition
those who know his work will
automatically see him as a natural
Scrooge while those who are new to his
work will be quickly convinced his
gruffness suits the character perfectly
while his comedy chops come in handy
towards the end Stewart is an actor at
the height of his powers in this
adaptation As Natural rolling his eyes
at orphans as he is embracing tiny tin
him he gives the entire production
gravity and he loans every scene in
setpiece weights and sophistication with
his presence this take on a Christmas
carol helps you understand how Stuart's
career has if anything only grown with
Age the movie around him in contrast is
merely fine there's nothing to complain
about but beyond Stuart's Powerhouse
performance nothing catches the eye
that's easily forgiven thanks to Stuart
but when placed beside other versions of
the story it's a lot more noticeable
Stuart is talented enough to make the
production notable but in truth he's the
only thing that does happily for Dickens
and Stewart fans alike A Christmas Carol
is very much a Bena scrooges story thus
this time it's Patrick Stewart's story
as well what the Dickens have they done
to Scrooge the tagline of the Scrooge
poster pleads it's also a musical and
one made in 1970 at that you hear these
facts and imagine a sort of perfect
anti- storm approaching and yet
Scrooge actually ends up being pretty
delightful yes it enjoys summing its
nose at the ideas of the Victorian era
and what a literary adaptation should be
but it's heart is fixed firmly in the
right place and that results in a truly
wonderful rendition of A Christmas Carol
the song served the story rather than
smothering it clarifying Dickens themes
as they spin them into an entirely new
medium is this gantier than the more
classical takes on the story yes but
that's a virtue Scrooge might be making
its own rules but it never loses sight
of its source material there's no
shortage of Christmas Carol adaptations
featuring Top Class Talent especially in
the role of Scrooge but George C Scott
brings something a match to this version
a sheer power that pours from every
frame an actor from West Virginia brings
something to a role as essentially
British as ebena Scrooge that the actual
Brits could do well to learn from him
this is a Scrooge Who strides and whose
nastiness stings all the more for the
force he can put behind it thus it's
also a scrooge who feels entirely
transformed by the final credits and a
scrooge who delivers the moral with
Renewed Energy he hasn't just changed by
his ordeal with the ghost but rebuilt as
a new man with new purpose alongside a
cast that brings a certain one quality
many Carol adaptations like Scott shines
or the brighter it's not just a great
take on a classic story or a collection
of impressive performances it's a
holiday treasure all its own who' have
thought that a rendition of A Christmas
Carol starring Muppets would be one of
the best adaptations of all unlike the
worst offenders on this list this film
doesn't just trut out the morals
everyone expects it also doesn't put any
unnecessary new spin on things that
don't need changing rather it highlights
the best things about the story while
providing a new lens with which to view
them thus it helps just loved them like
we did the very first time we heard the
story to start with there's Michael Kane
Scrooge he's as grouchy as he should be
but surrounding him with puppets teases
out a comical Edge he's a terror but
you're laughing at him from the
beginning this makes the movie an ideal
choice for the youngest viewers but it
also gives a film and inventive spin on
dickens's tail while some on this list
succeed by leaning into the story's
darker elements The Muppets succeed by
embracing the author's sense of humor
joy and Goodwill plus you will get to
see Gonzo best known for his weird blue
nose and love of chickens play cultural
Cornerstone Charles Dickens what's not
to love what makes a Christmas carol
great there's a satisfaction of seeing a
villain confronted with the consequences
of his actions there's a sight sense of
humor that Peaks out from around the
story's most cynical Corners plus
there's the community spirit that it
celebrates but beyond all that there's
the hope it Kindles A Christmas Carol
tells us that it's never too late to be
a bigger better and more benevolent
person I shall change my way of living I
will try to keep Christmas all the year
it's this spirit that the 1938
adaptation in bodies from its first
scenes to its Sublime ending it's a
beacon of progress in all its forms
reinard Owen Scrooge is an old monster
who finds himself falling in love with
life again flush with the fact that it
isn't too late for him that this film
was made in the midst of the Great
Depression for a weary public remains
clear this is a movie for those all too
familiar with Scrooge and his elk as
Dickens audience was in its day this
version of A Christmas Carol understands
the power of its story like few others
and decades after its debut it still
shin like it did the day of its
Premiere countless kids grew up with a
Christmas story and have gone from
watching it with youthful Wonder to
seeing it through older wiser eyes in
celebration of that inevitable shift in
perception here's a look at things only
adults notice in A Christmas Story one
of the Hallmarks of a Christmas story is
the rich Fantasy Life that Ralphie
indulges in on his road to Christmas Day
and hopefully his Red Rider BB gun the
most elaborate of these fantasies
involves him imagining what he might use
the gun for as Bandits led by black Bart
attacked the family home forcing Ralphie
and his trusty new weapon to defend his
family it plays out like the perfect kid
fantasy of a Western in their very own
neighborhood but it takes a slightly
dark turn when at the end it's pretty
clear that Ralphy has killed Black
Bart's gang kids might not notice this
but the lulling tongues and crossed out
eyes suggest death and he was after all
shooting them yes it's just a fantasy
but it's a grim one for a kid who mostly
just wants to shoot Targets in the back
backyard Ralphie is 9 years old as most
of a Christmas story unfolds placing him
in a rather interesting in between age
he's young enough to still consider
things like Christmas and Santa Claus
the most important parts of his life and
to care deeply about things like Little
Orphan Annie secret Dakota rings but
he's also old enough to fancy himself
more mature than his younger brother
it's subtle but this budding maturity
comes out in a couple of key moments
when it becomes clear that Ralphie is
becoming interested in women when the
old man sets up the leg lamp for the
first time Ralphie basically cops a feel
of the thing and in both his fantasies
and in real life it's clear that he at
the very least wants his teacher to like
him he might even have a little crush on
Miss Shields Ralphie's quest for his Red
Rider BB gun culminates when feeling all
of the adults in his life have forsaken
him he decides to appeal directly to
Santa at the local department store on
Christmas Eve this backfires
spectacularly as Ralphie spends the
entire time waiting in line trying to
focus Fus on his goal only to forget
everything he was going to say when he
finally climbs the Towering North Pole
structure to make matters worse the
Santa at the top seems unusually
intimidating and even frightening to
ralphy's eyes as he panics amid a
closing store and a group of pushy elves
it's clear that Ralphie blew his shot
but what's less clear is why what about
his past history with Santa made him so
nervous about asking for something from
the big guy was he just psyched out by
all of the rejections that came before
or is it more
specific A Christmas Story is a tale of
kid concerns and kid perceptions so
everything in Ralphie's world is just a
little bit heightened this includes his
encounters with the bully scut farcus
who seems to lurk around every corner
and takes his sick Delight in the pain
of other kids to near super villain
levels at least until Ralphie finally
finds it within himself to fight back to
any kid watching bullying is if not a
reality at least a familiar abstract
concept they've had to deal with in
their lives so they may simply accept it
and move on with the story for adults
though there's a sense that the bullying
in A Christmas Story is particularly
dark in part because the adults
surrounding the children don't really do
that much about it and the kids don't
necessarily want them to farcus haunts
Ralphie and his friends all the time but
they don't tell on him flick walks into
class with a black eye one day and Miss
Shields pays little attention to it even
when Ralphie finally beats the hell out
of farcus his mother ignores the other
kid in the fight and focuses only on her
son never really stopping to ask what
happens it calls to mind a world in
which kids are in entirely on their own
and to Modern audiences that can be a
little scary Ralphie's father only ever
referred to as the old man is a typical
representation of a Midwestern father
figure in the early 20th century he's
Stern but not cruel caring but not
affectionate and distant But Not absent
he's a man's man and he spends most of
the film just trying to read his
newspaper and enjoy a little bit of
turkey while his sons get into trouble
around him if you look close enough
though there are little hints of
eccentricity in the old man's life he
insists on being being timed when he
changes attire for example and went
through the trouble of burying his major
award in the backyard and supposedly
playing Taps and tribute to it as he did
he even takes some time in the
department store to Skip Along With The
Wizard of Oz characters Ralphie doesn't
think much about it but there's more to
his old man than newspapers and furnace
battles he has a rich inner life that we
only see glimpses of despite being a
ubiquitous movie there are still things
about a Christmas story that some
viewers can't agree on a keep point of
contention comes Midway through when the
old man's beloved major award is broken
and he's unable to glue it back together
the mother readily admits to Breaking
the leg lamp but claims it was an
accident that happened while she was
watering plants some viewers believe her
While others think that she did it
deliberately because she was sick of
looking at the thing and indeed she does
confirm she thinks it's the ugliest lamp
I have ever seen in my entire life so
what really happened look at the
expression on her face just as she heads
into the front room with her watering
can knowing she will be alone with the
lamp for a moment and listen to the
sheer force of the breaking
sound she definitely meant to do it
these days we think of Christmas as a
season that begins roughly at the end of
Thanksgiving a period of weeks packed
with decorations shopping seasonal
programming and all manner of parties
and other events the way Ralphie
obsesses over Christmas in the film
you'd think that it would be similar for
him but in the 1940 is era in which the
film takes place that's just not the
case for the Parker family Christmas as
an observable holiday really only lasts
a couple of days they go and get the
Christmas tree then Christmas Eve
arrives shortly thereafter and the
family packs in a parade shopping
decorating and visits to Santa all in
one night there is no Black Friday no
long period of shipping gifts to the
front door no early December Christmas
parades and no long slog of Christmas
parties to March through on the way to
the big day The Parkers basically wait
until Christmas as a day to arrive and
then celebrate it's not a huge plot
point and kids might not notice it but
adults whose entire schedules are thrown
out of whack in December definitely do
the leg lamp in A Christmas Story has
become so iconic that it's almost more
famous than any of the film's actual
human characters but until it arrives at
the Parker's residence it could be
anything the old man comes home from
work one day says he's going to be
getting a major award that very night
and then a crate shows
up ah
fragile it must be Italian well I think
that says fragile honey oh yeah before
it does though the old man is just
musing aloud about what the award might
be and even dares to think that someone
might be sending him the D to his very
own bowling alley this raises a couple
of questions what does the old man do
for a living and what on Earth did he do
to earn a major award that could range
from a weird novelty lamp all the way to
a piece of commercial property we don't
learn much about the old man's work and
the fluidity of this moment and what
exactly might have happened just further
underlines a common kid truth they often
don't really know what their parents do
all day when the hard midwest winter
comes in A Christmas Story ralphy's
mother bundles up Randy in such a way
that Ralphie even compares it to deep
sea diving and Randy famously complains
that he's wearing so many layers that he
can't put his arms down once outside
Randy can't even get up off the ground
by himself because his movement is so
hampered it's comical but it also makes
you think of what exactly was supposed
to happen when he got to school Randy
couldn't very well pull all of that
stuff off by himself self so who is
doing it for him more importantly who
was rebundling him when it was time to
go home for the day somewhere in that
school there's a poor employee who had
to be on Randy Parker winterwear Duty
day after day and they very likely
weren't happy about it the old man in A
Christmas Story has many different
nemeses there's the furnace that won't
stop acting up in the basement the S
mobile that won't run right and of
course the dogs next door we know very
little about the Bumpus family in the
house beside The Parkers all we really
know is that they have a lot of dogs and
those dogs really hate the old man in an
almost pathological way they follow him
from his car to his door try to push
their way into the house and ultimately
Devour the family's turkey when the
doors left open just enough for them to
get through and wreak havoc dogs will be
dogs of course but the film doesn't tell
us what else is going on that allows
this to happen why hasn't the old man
marched over and had it out with Mr
Bumpus of course the plot answer is so
he still has to do battle with the dogs
but it's hard not to wonder how things
got this bad in the first place place a
Christmas story is a film that depends
in many ways upon seeing the world from
ralphy's point of view which means that
our perspective on the various other
members of the family is slightly skewed
and emphasizes Ralphie's father more
than his mother frequent rewatching of
the film reveals especially to an adult
audience that Mrs Parker is in fact a
much bigger part of ralphy's emotional
memory than we give her credit for yes
she's there for him after his fight with
farcus but she's also a tender presence
in other ways she leads the silly
Christmas carols in in the car has an
innate understanding of how ry's mind
works proves she has the most patience
of anyone in the family when it counts
and even reveals a moment of real
tenderness with her husband in the
film's final scene Mrs Parker is much
more than a put-upon wife and mother
within this story she has in many ways
an inner life that's just as rich as her
husband's one of the most famous scenes
in A Christmas Story is the moment when
Ralphie makes a mistake and utters the
curse which the movie renders as
oh
fud this moment and the resulting
Fallout is mostly about Ralphie getting
punished for cursing in the first place
and then blaming it on his friend
something a lot of kids have no doubt
done but while the kids are busy
relating to the punishment phase of that
story the adults are probably paying a
little more attention to the way
Ralphie's mother reacts A Christmas
Story is a PG movie so we don't hear Too
Many curses thrown around but Ralphie
makes a point of telling the audience
that he's heard that particular bad word
frequently from his father something
schwarz's mother even guesses over the
phone we as an audience also hear Mr
Parker's nonsensical cursing wasting up
from the furnace throughout the film so
we can guess at what else he might say
in other situations why then does Mrs
Parker seem to have no clue as to the
kind of words her husband might use in a
high stress moment whatever's going on
there this family has an unhealthy
relationship with profanity and they
need to all get on the same
page a Christmas eye patch and an attic
full of Easter eggs come and wrap these
hidden details in Christmas Story
Christmas we triple dog dare you in A
Christmas Story Ralphie thinks a way to
get his parents to Grant His Wish of
getting a Daisy Red Rider BB gun is by
writing an A+ essay about why it's the
perfect gift while he thinks his writing
is strong raly also knows her bribe
won't hurt so while other kids get their
teacher an apple he gets her a fruit
basket in the new movie A Christmas
Story Christmas Ralphie is a struggling
novelist in his meeting with a publisher
he gives a publisher some C that he
admits is a bribe in his internal
monologue as was the case back then the
bribe doesn't work and the bribe just
goes in a drawer in A Christmas Story
Ralphie has a lot of dreams about the
future in one of his dreams his paper is
such a success that his teacher Raves
about it and his classmates Loft him on
their shoulders as a Great Hero in
another fantasy Ralphie sees a future
where he goes blind because his mom
punishes him by forcing him to put soap
in his mouth in A Christmas Story
Christmas Ralph sees a future where he
wins a major literary award to the
shagrin of the publisher who rejected
him he also sees a future where his
Christmas Eve arrest turns his daughter
into a Teen Mom and his turn into a
member of The Sex Pistols then there's
the black Bart dream in the original
movie Young Ralphie saves everybody with
his BB gun and blackb threatens to come
back in the new movie Ralph takes on a
Clint Eastwood Vibe this time around
however Ralph can't save his family and
ultimately Falls in battle as an
optimistic child he's a hero as a
struggle grownup he fails in A Christmas
Story Ralphie describes his father as so
some men are Baptists others Catholics
my father was an oldmobile man in A
Christmas Story Christmas Ralph drives
an old Plymouth even more his car is
pretty beat up while his dad had seen
himself as a member of the pit crew in
the Indie 500 while there are some
similarities the differences seem to be
more prevalent there's a scene where
Ralph goes to buy a tree attempting to
emulate his dad's ability to negotiate
the best price instead of getting a
great deal he accidentally buys the
monster tree that the lot couldn't sell
even more while his dad is a model of
194s middle class success Ralph is a
struggling writer whose wife is
supporting the family though that's
actually a sign of progress from the
world of Housewives and working men the
original movie inhabits one thing stays
the same though Ralph is as devoted to
his kids as his dad was in A Christmas
Story Christmas Ralph has a Daydream
remembering all the perfect Christmases
his dad prided over they're basically a
series of images of the family presented
in Norman Rockwell esque illustrations
most are actually just Recreations of
Rockwell Classics the Montage is
fleeting but important as it brings to
mind the idea of living up to the old
American Christmas dream it also
hearkens to the look of the original
poster the poster for a Christmas story
was illustrated by Robert tanom yet
looked like one of Norman Rockwell's
classic depictions of Americana the 2012
sequel A Christmas Story 2 also had a
rockwellian post
it is appropriate that a movie set
during the Heyday of the greatest
Generation adopted a Norman Rockwell
aesthetic in its promotions even more
it's fitting that Ralph's daunting
attempt to encapsulate and recreate
these moments was referenced through
these classic
illustrations once you're a parent
people are considerably less interested
in what you want for Christmas maybe
that's because what you wanted you get
older is often less fun than the hottest
new toy in A Christmas Story Ralphie's
dad says he wants a new furnace for
Christmas several times we see his dad
head to the basement to fight their
furnace with a string of explo lives and
a sound of clanging echoing throughout
the house in A Christmas Story Christmas
Ralph starts off by asking for his dream
gift a time machine to go back to the
beginning of the year when he and his
wife had agreed he could have a year to
pursue his writing career full time then
he mentions the more realistic gift a
new radiator for his car we see his
car's constant radiator issues which he
fixes with an egg so maybe Ralph and his
dad are more alike than they thought
seeing as they both come to understand
that the Practical things in life
sometimes take precedence to less
grounded hopes and dreams uh Merry
Christmas in A Christmas Story Christmas
Ralph returns to his childhood home for
a Christmas unlike any other seeing as
it would be his first Christmas without
his dad the home looks the same sure but
it's in the Attic where we find the real
Treasures Ralph goes up to the attic
looking for the Christmas ornaments but
it's thrown back into his old childhood
while digging through his parents' junk
there are tons of nods to the first
movie up there yeah opens one box and
finds a pink bunny costume a gift from
his aunt claraa he looks like a deranged
Easter Bunny and he casually tosses
aside the shade to his father's bizarre
leg lamp as a strain of sultry Lounge
music plays for a brief second he also
gets infuriated when he finds a plastic
Christmas tree his mother had bought and
decides the first thing to do is to go
get a real Christmas tree there is some
irony in the fact that his father had
said he was thinking of maybe buying a
plastic tree of course his dad only said
this as a negotiate tactic to get the
Christmas tree salesman to throw in a
piece of rope and tie the tree onto the
family's
Oldsmobile home in is a fictitious
Midwestern City a miltown it would seem
set up to represent any Town USA the
central part of Home in is of course a
great department store downtown known as
Higg bees in A Christmas Story Ralphie
describes reving at the Higg bees window
and in A Christmas Story Christmas he's
still just as impressed when they go
into Higg bees the elves have the same
costume the setup as a slide down from
Santa to the point that Ralph warns his
children about getting a boot in the
face ho ho
ho and Santa is still a distraction for
the kids while their parents sharp
there's even a creepy kid in front of
the children in line who pukes when it's
finally his turn to talk to Santa there
are differences though mom and grandma
sit in the lounge drinking while Dad
does all the shopping Julie is a shrewd
negotiator with Santa unlike her father
and this time around we get to see the
Mad Dash of pre- Internet gift shopping
that today is relegated to Gen X and
older Nostalgia there are few more
memorable lines from any Christmas movie
than sh your
sh in A Christmas Story Ralphie's mom
says it his teacher says it even Santa
says it to him this simple but famous
line was what everyone told him about
why he shouldn't get a BB gun and sure
enough the first time he shoots the
rifle a BB Ricochet is into his glasses
since his glasses saved him though the
there are no eye injuries in his family
that is until he pegs his daughter with
a snowball in A Christmas Story
Christmas in A Christmas Story Christmas
to seen that most cement Ralph's role as
a good dad is not the gift hunting or
the desire to make them stronger or
deliver the perfect Christmas we see him
launch into an unabashedly joyous
snowball fight with his kids as his car
cools down and we instantly realize how
much he loves his family all is going
well until Ralph turns to launch a
distant snowball at his son Mark and
inadvertently hits his daughter Julie in
the eye at Point Blank Range as a result
Judy ends up with an eye patch the
inclusion of a grown flick and Schwarz
and A Christmas Story Christmas was a
highlight for anybody who grew up with
the movie and wondered what ever
happened to their own childhood friends
of course in the original film you'd
maybe only know them as Ralphie's friend
who stuck his tongue to a pole flick and
the one who Triple Dog dared him Schwarz
these days flick owns a bar where
Schwarz is a barfly you can't help but
feel bad for flick for the tongue thing
so it's a wonderful moment to see him
gets his revenge in A Christmas Story
Christmas in the new film he tripled dog
de Schwarz to jump into a snowy field by
going down a frozen slide Schwarz gets
his comeuppence and like all good
friends they follow it with some all his
forgiven
camaraderie it seems like an odd choice
to have Ralphie grow up to be a writer
but in A Christmas Story he does have a
scene of divine inspiration while
writing his essay on why he should get a
Daisy Red Rider BB gun Ralphie describes
the words just flowing out of him into
what no doubt would be a magnificent
story in A Christmas Story Christmas
grownup Ralph goes to the attic now
having failed to get both his book
published and his kids Christmas
presents he describes how the words pour
out of him as he writes about his father
for what was supposed to be his dad's
eulogy in A Christmas Story the essay
doesn't get the grade or reaction he'd
hoped yet in A Christmas Story Christmas
this flow of inspiration yields a story
so captivating that it lands on the
front page of the local paper there is a
Time oned tradition of children running
through the meticulously wrapped gifts
they've received The Parkers are no
different what is fun to see though is
how similar Mark and Julie are to Ralph
and Randy when they were kids the chaos
at his Christmas gift opening was
captured perfectly in A Christmas Story
and The Echoes In A Christmas Story
Christmas hit just as hard it starts off
controlled and respectful but then it
quickly explodes into a chaotic scene of
tearing apart wrapping paper even more
in A Christmas Story Ralphie and Randy
both open socks at the same time they
look at their boring gifts then
disinterestedly throw the socks over
their shoulders and get back into
tearing apart wrapping paper in A
Christmas Story Christmas Mark and judie
get books and throw those over their
shoulders before getting back to work
proving whether we're talking about the
1940s or the 1970s One Thing Remains the
Same kids have no problem running
through their gifts in search of the
ones they actually like there's a lot to
relate to in A Christmas Story but few
parents can deny that possibly the best
scene is when Ralphie's Mom and Dad get
to sit in a chair together in the dark
having success successfully pulled off
yet another Christmas A Christmas Story
Christmas has its own version of the
scene but it's a little different after
all Ralph's dad is gone or is he instead
of Ralph's Mom and Dad basking in the
glow of the tree after all the chaos of
the holiday it's now Ralph and his mom
although this time Ralph and his mom are
worried about the future and missing
Ralph's father then the fuse blows and
of course it happens right when Ralph
and his mom bring up Ralph's dad because
if anything indicates that old man
Parker's spirit is still with them it's
a fuds blowing under a Christmas tree
and right when it seemed the only thing
missing was the old man he was here just
like
always when we think of The Simpsons
holiday episodes our thoughts
immediately turn to Halloween due to the
wildly successful Treehouse of Horror
Stories however Springfield's favorite
family has starred in plenty of
Christmas adventures in fact here are 15
of them ranked from worst to best
according to fans on
IMDb aired in December 2006 kill Gil
volumes 1 and 2 finds The Simpsons
taking pity on Springfield's eternally
down on his luck businessman Gil they
even invite him to stay at their home
for Christmas unfortunately Marge has a
hard time saying no and Gil ends up
crashing at their place for 11 months
they're are hilarious 11 months to be
sure but they push Marge and the family
to the Edge by the time Marge finally
works up the gumption to kick Gil out
she discovers that he just left on his
own however with the need for closure
the family drives all the way to Arizona
so Marge can tell Gil exactly how she
feels like most Simpsons episodes this
one is packed with great lines but
there's one that stands Above the Rest
why did you let that loser into our home
I'll tell you why Christian charity
Christian charity what does a porn star
have to do with this in the episode
White Christmas blues climate change has
made it far too hot for snow to fall
throughout the vast majority of America
except for Springfield as it turns out
pollution from the town's nuclear power
plant combines with smoke from its
perpetually burning tire yard to create
freak conditions allowing for snow so an
influx of tourists Dash into Springfield
to experience a traditional White
Christmas the town becomes so overrun
that hotels are turning people away in
need of holiday money Marge decides to
take in some borders despite Homer's
objections uh-uh no way I'm not sharing
my bed with anybody except you it maybe
that guy Lincoln style but that's it
eventually the guests become so rude and
demanding that they nearly destroy the
Simpsons holiday spirit but we all know
that Marge would never let that happen
The Fight Before Christmas would go down
as a pretty standard Simpsons holiday
episode were it not for the final of its
four Christmas themed segments to wrap
the episode up the Simpson switches its
format from animation to puppetry and
the cast turns into fullon felt and
stuffing Muppets this sudden switch was
pretty stunning to some fans but the
show had yet another surprise lined up
after being edited out of a Sesame
Street episode for dressing in a way
that some people considered too risque
for a children show Katy Perry drops by
The Simpsons holiday special for a
liveaction celebrity Cameo unfortunately
even that wasn't enough to impress some
viewers last night I had a visit from
three Spirits I wish this show had a
visit from three New
Riders penned by Og Simpsons writer and
longtime showrunner Al jeene I won't be
home for Christmas finds Marge enraged
when Homer stays out late on Christmas
Eve however Homer only gets held up
because Mo needs some company to help
him through an extra ult spell of
holiday related loneliness this season
26 episode makes plenty of gestures
toward emphasizing the importance of
family and togetherness and all that but
without any genuine conflict the story
Glides through your brain without
leaving much to remember it by although
in one scene Homer stumbles across Gil
in a movie theater which raises the
question why is Gil in so many Simpsons
holiday episodes we're not even in the
top 10 yet and he's already popped up
twice once again Gil manages to find his
way into yet another Simpsons Christmas
special in TI the 30th season Marge
rescues Gil from being trampled at a
Black Friday sale and helps him secure a
plush toy for his grandchild later in
the episode Homer and the kids decide to
give Marge a break for the holidays and
the family heads to Florida the only
problem is that Homer books them a room
in a seriously dingy Motel plus the
nearby theme park isn't any better with
its shabby Hall of vice presidents and
assortment of bizarre cartoon character
mascots TI the 30th season also marks
another instance of the show's writers
parodying the famous horse head scene
from The
Godfather
[Music]
I shot my best friend in the
face Simpson's Christmas Story stands as
the second Anthology episode on this
list and includes three holiday Tales
the middle story is the real standout
here and focuses on Grandpa reminiscing
to Bart and Lisa about why he wants to
kill Santa Claus without giving too much
away this 2005 episode features the
first and last appearance of great uncle
Cyrus Simpson who lives in Tahiti with
his 15 wives and presum presumably
several Simpsons cousins and second
cousins it also boasts an amazing
flashback sequence of a young Grandpa
and Mr Burns marooned on an island where
Santa and his reindeer find themselves
in some dangerous situations I'm just
missing Prancer and
Rudolph in TI the 15th season Homer
demonstrates ample selfishness by buying
an expensive Gizmo for himself severely
limiting the rest of the family's
Christmas budget after watching a Mr meu
inspired cartoon that mimics A Christmas
Carol Homer decides to be the most
charitable person in town instead of a
selfish o this development enrages Ned
Flanders because being charitable is his
trademark later in the episode Homer
pulls a Grinch who stole Christmas
because Lisa tells him everyone would be
happier if Society was a little less
materialistic as a whole Tis the 15th
season demonstrates how television
writers can copy and paste pre-existing
pop culture and explain that their
intent was satire or homage as opposed
to exploring new ideas when Homer tells
his family about the cartoon he watched
Lisa explains to him that the story line
is nothing new dad what you saw was A
Christmas Carol it was written by
Charles Dickens 160 years ago yeah TV
writers have been milking that goat for
years after Mr Burns pays for repairs at
Reverend Lovejoy Church during season
13's she of little faith the heartless
Miser insists that the place of worship
be covered in advertising upset by the
feckless capitalism and trivialized
spirituality Lisa converts to Buddhism
With a Little Help from guest star
Richard Gear once again the Simpson
stumbles into the Paradox that has sunk
other episodes it wants to use religion
for comedic purposes but runs up against
an imperative to never suggest that
mainstream religion is funny luckily
this episode doesn't feel like a
copout
go you'll get yours during the story's
second half marg's campaign to lure Lisa
back into the flock gets so manipulative
that even Homer gives her an incredulous
glance making this a rare Simpsons
episode in which Homer plays the voice
of reason in season 11's grift of the
Magi kid first Industries bails out
Springfield Elementary and much like The
Narrative of she of little faith
commercialization runs totally a muck
quite unlike she of little faith this
episode features a celebrity Cameo from
Gary Coleman that feels inspired and
purposeful in contrast to Richard gears
walk-on it's hard to say how many
members of the television viewing public
under 40 years old have ever seen
Different Strokes but even if younger
fans don't recognize Coleman plenty of
viewers know that he delivered one of
the best Simpsons cameos ever I'm sorry
Gary there's no longer a place for you
here what you talking about Miss Nagel
that is so adorable you're rehired the
way of the dog is a 2020 episode that
finds Santa's Little Helper losing
control of his unresolved emotional
issues which leads him to getting a
little bitey with Marge a dog
behaviorist voiced by Kate Blanchet
figures out that his problems are
related to Trauma from when he was a
puppy so The Simpsons track down a dog
trainer who proudly admits to separating
their Pooch from his mother of course
the family has a Perfectly Natural
reaction to this
news the episode ends with the Simpsons
bringing home Santa's little helper's
mother the perfectly named she biscuit
Bart accidentally melts the family's
plastic Christmas tree and destroys all
of their presence in the episode Miracle
on Evergreen Terrace being Bart he
blames the whole Fiasco on an imaginary
burglar after a news report airs about
the supposed break-in the residents of
Springfield rallied together to give The
Simpsons a Merry Christmas when when the
truth eventually comes out there's an
understandable backlash against the
family the final few minutes in which
the town righteously loots 742 Evergreen
Terrace are easily the funniest few of
the entire
episode you're heading for the medicine
cabinet I already been there in
Skinner's sense of snow a blizzard traps
Bart Lisa and plenty of other students
at Springfield Elementary during the
final day before winter break most of
the jokes in the episode revolve around
principal Skinner's futile attempt to
maintain order eventually Skinner starts
to lose his cool and takes his
frustrations out on grounds keeper
Willie that's the last time you'll slap
your Willie around I quit there are also
a few apparent lapses of in story logic
here and not necessarily the kind we can
wave off just because it's a cartoon
Lisa Revels in anti-establishment chaos
in a manner that clashes with the highly
respectful attitude toward the education
system she usually displays plus Skinner
spends much of the episode second and
half stuck in a dodgeball bag that
doesn't seem like it should be able to
bind an adult human speaking of
Skinner's adulthood this episode aired
in 2000 and States his age as 40 but in
a flashback it also depicts him as an
adult Soldier during the Vietnam war for
many fans some of the most memorable
Simpsons episodes and segments take
place in the future it's always fun to
see how much Lisa has achieved and how
little Bart has changed the 2011 episode
holidays of Future Past is no exception
30 years in the future The Simpsons
reunite to spend Christmas together
along the way we learned that Lisa is a
successful businesswoman and with her
husband Milhouse has an angsty teenage
daughter Bart of course is a down andout
divorced dad but the big surprise here
is that Maggie is a world famous rock
star and she recently gave birth to her
first child the story also features
ungrateful Simpson grandkids dozens of
adult Ralph wigam clones and an
unusually optimistic vision of Homer as
an old man but the emotional highlight
of the episode occurs when Bart and Lisa
have a few too many drinks in their old
Treehouse and Bart makes a confession to
his overachieving sister at least you're
the person I always wanted to
[Music]
be the series premiere of the longest
running scripted television show in the
history of the medium almost feels too
historic to be contextualized as one of
several specific Simpsons episodes but
then again it is very much a Simpsons
holiday special even if it might also be
other things of equal or greater
significance it took the Simpsons until
roughly Eight Episodes into its second
season to really figure itself out and
rise to the immaculate level we
associate with the show but Simpsons
roasting on an open fire certainly
contains hints of the absurdity
irreverent self-awareness and heart that
was coming down the pipeline maybe hints
is putting it too lightly Homer's stint
as a m Santa is very absurd Bart's
dialogue is already very irreverent and
self-aware and the family's decision to
give Santa's Little Helper a forever
home even though he failed to win them a
dime at the racetrack checks off the
heart box for sure ironically the top
ranking Simpsons holiday episode
according to fans isn't really about
Christmas to put it more precisely Marge
be not proud isn't addressing
boilerplate generalized themes about
family or togetherness instead it's the
definitive Bart episode with Christmas
functioning as a plot device in the
story the eldest Simpson child gets
busted shoplifting a video game and
Marge responds as if it's the worst
thing he's ever done sure Bart caused an
international incident as recently as
the previous season but in terms of the
kind of non- Fantastical Mischief that a
10-year-old boy could commit in real
life ripping off the try and save is his
greatest transgression Bart puts actual
effort into reestablishing the doting
motherson Dynamic he rejects at the
beginning of the episode when he claims
he's not a little kid anymore while he's
happy to play the part of his
generation's Dennis the Menace he
doesn't want his Mayhem to go too far
and alienate his family or for that
matter his audience Marge be not proud
established a rule The Simpsons has more
or less followed since Bart's
Shenanigans must remain either two car t
for reality or too harmless for anyone
to take seriously his character walks
that fine line and usually caps it off
with one of his many catchphrases eat my
shorts selfish elves a Santa kidnapping
and a candy fueled creeper we love Elf
but there are a few things you won't be
able to ignore next time you watch it at
its heart elf is a classic Fish Out of
Water comedy but with the added twist
being that the fish Buddy the elf
doesn't fit in back in the water either
the movie's opening scenes show us some
great physical comedy as the 6'3 will
frell squeezes himself into elf-sized
showers and beds but here's the thing
why don't the elves just you know make
him a bed one of the things that makes
the movie feel heartwarming and christmy
is that the other elves up at Santa's
Workshop are generally pretty nice to
Buddy they even take time to reassure
him that he's got his own special
talents when he starts to feel like he
doesn't fit in and even if they get
frustrated behind his back it's clear
that they care about him so why in the
30 years that he's been there haven't
they made the slightest adjustment to
their housing situation so that he's not
destroying his spine every night it's
not like it would take them that long
building things is literally all the
elves do and a king-sized bed frame and
Mattress surely wouldn't take as much
time to Cobble together as say building
a PlayStation 5 from scratch he's not
even the only one there who needs
human-sized furniture since Santa Claus
also lives there and has been doing so
for about 1500 years even if the elves
aren't the ones who made his furniture
just order another mattress and put it
on the floor it's not great but it's
better than sleeping with all your limbs
hanging off the bed the odd thing about
Buddy the elf is that he never seems to
notice that he's roughly three times
taller than everyone he knows well
almost everyone The Only Exception is
Santa Claus but he's still taller than
Santa but not to the extent that it is
with the other elves if anything buddy
should probably assume that he's a Santa
or at least some other kind of human the
only reason that buddy thinks he's an
elf at all is that after accidentally
kidnapping him when buddy was an infant
Santa pulls the very UNS santal likee
move of keeping him and handing him off
to the elves this by the way is not what
you should do if you ever find a baby
Buddy's naiv is at the core of the film
but there's a fine line between his
Earnest good-natured belief that a
random Diner really did perfect the
world's best cup of coffee and the kind
of oblivious ignorance of just not being
able to put simple Clues together you
did it
congratulations world's best cup of
coffee great job everybody you'd think
that if you can figure out how to build
85 etes sketches in a single day you'd
be a little bit better at putting things
together pass the Sea of swirly twirly
gumdrops and then I walked through the
Lincoln Tunnel this is going to sound
pretty nitpicky for a movie where we're
willing to accept that Santa Claus can
fly around the world in a single night
giving all the good children presents
but the fact that buddy Walks from the
North Pole to Manhattan is a little
ridiculous there are a lot of reasons
for that primarily the fact that it's a
straight shot of about 3,400 mil from
Santa's Workshop to Manhattan even if
we're willing to accept that the iceberg
he floats off on takes him down to
Canada that's still leaves him in the
nunav with 2900 Mi left to go we'll give
you that his elf clothes are magical and
able to keep him warm at the North Pole
and Below but still no matter how hyped
up he is on maple syrup and candy canes
that's a long and potentially or let's
be real here almost certainly fatal
Journey for someone who's completely
unprepared for it now here's why this
isn't as much of a nitpick as it seems
like the scene sticks out because this
is a movie with Santa in it the guy has
a magic flying sleigh that can cover 212
million miles in a single night sure
he's a busy guy around the holidays but
are we really meant to believe that
Santa Claus can't take 0.4 seconds out
of his day so that he doesn't have to
deal with a singing penguin finding a
dead body in the candy cane Forest after
the spring thaw you like sugar huh is
there sugar and syrup yes then yes one
of the biggest sources of Comedy
throughout elfl is Buddy's ridiculously
candy Centric diet after all he hails
from a land of Christmas cheer that was
inspired by the rank and bass stop
motion specials of the' 60s so he grew
up on a steady diet of candy canes and
describes the North Pole's four food
groups as candy candy canes candy corns
and syrup of course that means buddy
should be straight up dead you probably
figured this out for yourself in the
days after Halloween when you were a kid
but a diet that consists entirely of
candy isn't just unhealthy it's also a
great way to get type 2 diabetes sure
you could explain it away by saying that
all the candy at the North Pole is
suffused with Christmas magic that makes
it delicious and nutritious but after he
comes to New York buddy keeps up his
standard habits drowning a plate of
spaghetti with an entire bottle of maple
syrup and washing it down by slamming an
entire 2 L bottle of Coca-Cola in fact
the few things we see him eat in the
movie that aren't candy or a bottle of
booze and a Jar full of cotton balls fun
fact in real life those cotton balls
were actually cotton candy if you need
any evidence that wolfing down that much
sugar was a bad idea look no further
than will frell himself in interviews
about the film since its release he's
talked about how he lost sleep while the
movie was being filmed thanks to the
constant sugar intake multiply that by
30 plus years worth of sugarcoated meals
and you've got health problems that go
Way Beyond a little insomnia and into
the territory of having your heart
explode while chugging maple syrup did
you sleep okay last night great I got a
full 40 minutes just 5 years away from
Iron Man John favro was the man who
directed elf and he even has a small
part as the Hobs family's friendly
physician he also provides the voice of
the north Po's resident narwhal bye
buddy hope you find your dad and while
we're talking about feo's doctor we'd be
remiss if we didn't cover what might be
the worst medical decision ever
committed to film after performing a DNA
test to confirm that yes buddy is in
fact Walter's biological son the doctor
advises Walter to take Buddy home to
meet his wife and son in hopes that
he'll eventually come to terms with the
situation and drop the whole elf thing
and move on obviously that all works out
for Buddy and the Hobs family but by any
measure this is some truly terrible
advice both Walter and the doctor are
operating under the assumption that
buddy is extremely delusional any
medical professional worth a stethoscope
would most likely suggest that they get
buddy some immediate treatment
psychiatric or otherwise before his
disconnect with reality leads to more
violence that's right more violence the
scene with the blood test happens
directly after Walter Bale's buddy out
of jail after he assaults a department
store Santa at gimbals in other words
the doctor is confronted with a
delusional man with a very recent
history of violence and his solution of
this problem is to take him home to your
wife and kid here's hoping the first
thing the Hobs family does after the
credit's role is get themselves a new
general practitioner your
father well he's on the NAU list no the
driving conflict of elf is that Walter
Hobbs Buddy's long-lost human father has
landed himself squarely on the naughty
list the reason well in addition to just
being a fairly unpleasant person and all
those murders he did in The Godfather
Walter has been neglecting his family
and focusing too much on his work this
is the to plenty of Christmas movies
about learning how to love your family
more effectively under the boot heel of
consumerism but there's something
different about Walter's story he's
genuinely terrible at his job normally
the person in this kind of plot who's
obsessing over their work is at least
successful in that Arena which makes it
more effective when they have to choose
what's really important Walter's got
plenty of money that apartment at
Central Park West doesn't come cheap but
as far as the work goes he's hardly a
success his company's floundering and
they're downturn is a direct result of
decisions that he made or rather due to
decisions that he didn't make despite
filling the role of the workaholic who
spends too much time at the office
Walter doesn't actually seem to care
about anything that he's doing at work
to the point of approving a proof of a
book that was missing two pages even the
most inept employee would notice if he
was initialing two gigantic blank pages
so the simple fact is that Walter just
doesn't care that raises a pretty Grim
question though if he's neglecting his
family for work but he's not actually
doing any work is he just sitting there
taking as much time away from his wife
and son as he can so that he can stare
off into space and contemplate Oblivion
that is dark I like
[Music]
it I like it the major drama at the
climax of the film centers around
whether Santa SLE is going to be able to
fly without the engine that's been
keeping it going all these years see
without the engine the Sligh has to rely
entirely on the magic of Christmas cheer
to power it around the world and
according to the clausometer there's
just not enough Christmas spirit to do
the job but that doesn't make sense this
is a world where Santa Claus is 100%
actually factually real with a toy
factory at the North Pole staffed by
cheerful singing elves a talking snowman
and everything that goes along with him
he brings presence to The Good Children
all over the world which means that
there's no disillusionment or
disappointment from kids who didn't get
what they wanted on Christmas morning we
we also know from the movie that getting
a present does in fact increase your
Christmas spirit as Michael Walter's
other son boosts the clausometer a
little bit when he gets the skateboard
he's always wanted so if Santa and the
elves have been doing their job and as
far as we know they have then there
should be more than enough Christmas
spirit to go around just from that let
alone all the general feel-good
Sentiments of peace on Earth Goodwill
hot chocolate and so
on one of the things that makes elf such
a favorite around the holidays is that
it's an almost relentlessly cheerful
film without getting too sugary sweet
but he spaghetti not withstanding in
fact the closest it gets to anything
you'd call dark would be the depiction
of the Santa hating Central Park Rangers
at the end oh and that one part where
buddy commits felony assault on an
innocent man for the crime of dressing
up as Santa Claus but even if Buddy's
sudden temper is slightly out of
character that all makes perfect sense
in the context of the movie what happens
after however seems like a stretch since
the original gimbals Santa is no longer
available the toy Department's manager
has to fill in and frankly that's
ridiculous if you've ever been to Macy's
around Christmas time then you already
know that these stores take their Santa
setup very seriously it's a lot more
complicated than just one dude sitting
on a big chair asking kids what they
want for Christmas the gimbals we see in
the movie might not be as dedicated to
it as Macy's of course historically the
real life gimbals was Macy's competitor
until shutting down in 1987 with with
their rivalry cementing itself into
Christmas movie history is a plot point
in the original Miracle on 34th Street
still the idea that a store that big
wouldn't have at least a couple of
backup Santas is somehow more difficult
to believe than the flying
reindeer Buddy's romance with joy a
young woman working as an elf at gimbals
played in a star making turn by Zoe de
Chanel ends up being pretty sweet but it
has a rocky start most people don't wind
up going on dates with strangers who
sneak up on them in the shower no matter
how nice they are about your singing
afterwards considering that elf has a
runtime of just over 90 minutes it makes
sense that things have to move pretty
fast to get everything wrapped up by the
time the credits roll still Jo's awfully
quick to forgive buddy for creeping up
on her in the shower especially since
the next two interactions she has with
him involve him beating up the guy
playing Santa Claus and then telling her
that his tongue swells up around her and
asking if she wants to go eat food I
feel really warm when I
around you the fact that she goes out
with them at all let alone ends up in
happy elfant matrimony after it's all
said and done is well it's a Christmas
miracle the weirdest part of all of this
might be one that Joie would have no way
of knowing but that we and the audience
can Peg as what might be the only lie
buddy tells in the whole movie when she
asks if he was spying on her in the
shower he replies I didn't know you were
naked this seems plausible given Buddy's
naive nature that the thing is he
definitely knew she was in the shower
and we actually see buddy showering in
an elf-sized tub earlier in the movie of
course he did have his hat on at the
time so maybe elves are a rare class of
never nudes oh I'm sorry you know I need
you to be completely undressed I am
completely undressed there are any
number of ways to tell a child that they
are adopted though perhaps no worse way
than for them to overhear it from two
co-workers bad mouthing their Etch A
Sketch production output but he learns
the hard way that he's not an elf and
while you might reasonably expect him to
come to that conclusion after a decade
or two it's also not unreasonable to
expect Papa elf and Santa to have had
that conversation directly saving buddy
a bundle of unnecessary trauma Santa's
judgment in regards to the whole buddy
situation becomes even more suspect
considering the fact that he's
apparently had all the information
needed to reunite buddy with his father
for years it would be one thing if Buddy
were simply an anonymous orphan who
crawled into Santa sack one year and in
that case it would make a certain amount
of sense for Santa to take the human
baby in and raise it at the North Pole
but Santa also knows the name of Buddy's
mother Susan Wells the circumstances of
her death the name of his still living
father Walter Moss Walter's job and the
location of his office and the fact that
Walter is on the naughty list he only
reveals this information when his hand
is forced as buddy inadvertently
discovers the truth while it's hard to
hate on Santa Claus all of this points
to a serious lapse of judgment on the
big big guy's part the scene featuring
Future Game of Thrones star Peter
Dinklage as hot shot children's book
author miles fch is cringe inducing but
purposely so Walter has bribed miles to
come into the office and help his
clueless in-house writers with a new
book pitch he's hoping this pitch will
be the thing that gets Walter back in
good with his boss and save his job but
before miles can get into his potential
storyline buddy barges into the meeting
and mistakes the man for an elf miles
takes offense at Budd Bud's sincere
excitement to see a fellow elf as a
crack about his height and while he
tries to keep his cool eventually
Buddy's insults become too much to bear
miles runs across the boardroom table
and drop kcks him that all makes sense
even if in illustrating Buddy's
insensitivity the film itself gets a
little insensitive what doesn't make
much sense is how no one else in this
scene not Walter his writers or his
secretary does anything to break up the
fight as miles chokes buddy to the
ground and breaks breaks every lighting
fixture and piece of glass wear in the
room along the way they all just sit
there apparently Frozen and shock until
the scene ends with Walter angrily
disowning buddy every year it seems that
someone on the internet discovers and is
newly horrified by the scene in which
buddy banished to The Greenway press
mail room for irritating Walter makes
friends with and accidentally gets day
drunk with a worker played by Mark aeson
as they reclin on a pair of rolling
cards full of padded envelopes declaring
themselves best friends mail room guy as
he is credited laments the direction
that his life is taken he just goes with
the flow but now he needs to get out of
the flow I'm 26 years old I got nothing
to show you're young you're so young
Ates was in fact 46 years old when the
film was released and while he may
appear relatively youthful for a
46-year-old he makes for an alarmingly
craggy gravel voiced 26-year-old mail
room guy works in a chaotic processing
room with no s of natural light he
drinks from a half pint of hard liquor
on the job and only has the job thanks
to a prison work relase program so the
impact of the gag makes for a worthy
suspension of
[Music]
disbelief